so the BBC reached out and said we want
to interview you I said we've got this
idea we want to take you to a park and
have you meet one of the protesters
who's been wielding his gun outside your
mosque and talked to him
it was really interesting because they'd
interviewed him before meeting me and
the things that he was able to utter
before meeting me and before meeting
Syrian refugees
was just awful I mean the most
dehumanizing rhetoric that you can
imagine
but then at the park he meets me talks
to me he meets a Syrian refugee family
uh one of the girls whose leg had been
blown off in an airstrike
and he said I feel like an idiot I mean
he expressed all sorts of regret
and was teary-eyed
that he could dehumanize people the way
that he was and so my whole thing was
and is come inside the mosque put your
gun down
disarm yourself and learn
and you'll be surprised what you'll walk
away with
and only took one meeting with him to
completely
shift
his worldview at the time
which
was made up of heroes and villains the
Muslims unfortunately being the villains
that had to be wiped off the face of the
Earth so that the Earth could continue
the following is a conversation with
Imam Dr Omar Suleiman he's a Muslim
scholar civil rights leader founder and
president of the yakin institute for
Islamic Research and he is a professor
of Islamic Studies at Southern Methodist
University he's one of the most
influential Muslims in the world and is
a Fearless kind-hearted human being who
I'm now proud to call a friend
as a side note allow me to say a few
words about Israel and Palestine
while this conversation with Omar
Suleiman was mostly exploring the
history and beauty of Islam and the
Muslim Community we did delve briefly
into the topic of Israel and Palestine
this topic is an extremely challenging
one and an extremely important one
it is Deep Roots and implications in U.S
politics in global geopolitics in
Military and religious conflicts Wars
and atrocities and basic struggle of all
human beings to survive to protect their
loved ones and to flourish as
individuals and as communities
I did not want to cover this topic in a
solely scholarly fashion much like with
the war in Ukraine it is not simply a
story of History politics religion and
national identity it is also a deeply
human story
to cover this topic in the way that my
gut and my heart says to do it I have to
talk to everyone to leaders and people
on all sides Muslim and Jewish Israeli
and Palestinian from refugees to
soldiers from Scholars to extremists
I'm not sure if that's possible
or wise but like Forrest Gump said I'm
not a smart man and maybe you know how
the rest of that goes
I just like to follow my heart to
whatever place it leads
I ask the Muslim and the Jewish
communities for your patience and
support as they explore this topic I
will make many mistakes and I'll be
listening to all voices so I can learn
and do better
I've become distinctly aware that my
Approach of talking to people from all
walks of life with empathy and
compassion but with backbone can create
enemies on all sides
I don't quite yet understand why this is
but I'm learning to accept it as the
reality of the world
hopefully in the end whatever happens
whatever silly thing I do has a chance
of adding a bit of love to the world
thanks for going along with me on this
journey
this is the Lex figment podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Omar Solomon
we've been trying to do this a long time
it's uh the world tried to prevent it
through the the funny ways that the
world does but uh here we are I'm a huge
fan of yours it's a huge honor to talk
to you I appreciate it thank you for
making the sacrifice and coming down for
coming up I guess I appreciate it it's a
short flight but a long journey let's
start with the biggest question who is
God according to Islam
God is
the most compassionate the most merciful
the creator of the heavens and the Earth
he is one God
he begets not nor is he begotten he's
unique
he is omnipotent he is beyond the
limitations of man
he is beyond the constructs of our
imagination
but he is ever accessible through
sincere supplication
when you call upon him
alone
one God he is closer to you than your
jugular vein the Quran tells us
he's known by many names and attributes
but his Essence is one he's one God no
human likeness
no human imperfection can be attributed
to him no partners
no image of him can be constructed
and that is God so God represents he is
a feeling of closeness that is
accessible to every human being well
God's Not A Feeling God is known by
names and attributes
we call upon God but
there is certainly a feeling of
closeness when you access him and so I
think the beauty of Islam is that
as perfect as God is described
he's also so accessible to the imperfect
and so the idea of sincere supplication
and connection to him we worship him
alone we call upon him alone there's no
clergy there's no barrier between God
and and us
and that encourages
a sincere devotion and commitment to him
alone and so he is certainly described
Supreme
and God speaks to us through the Quran
and we speak to him through sincere
supplication
and his attributes are the furthest from
us in terms of their perfection but he
is ever close to us through our
supplication through our prayers and
through our connection to him
to open the door to that connection to
have a connection with God how difficult
is that process how difficult was it for
you how difficult is it for the people
that for the many many many Muslims that
you've interacted with
well I think that there are different
layers of difficulty Right There Is the
personal difficulty submitting yourself
to God you know Islam requires a
complete submission to him and
one of the things that happens is that
if we
project
some of our bad experiences with
authority onto our relationship with God
then we immediately perceive him in a
certain way that might not allow us to
gain a closeness to him because maybe we
didn't have the best relationship with
our parents growing up maybe we didn't
have the best relationship with
authority figures in our lives and so
this idea of an ultimate authority to
whom you submit yourself can be very
difficult you know Malcolm X who was one
of the most prominent converts to Islam
in American history talked about the
difficulty of prostration for the very
first time putting your head on the
ground putting your face on the ground
and praying to God is a very humbling
thing submitting all of your Affairs to
him is very humbling
and ultimately you have to relinquish
control and you can't relinquish control
without trust so you have to learn to
trust God to trust God you have to know
him and to know him is to love him and
so
for me personally you know growing up uh
going through certain difficulties
having a sick parent who struggled uh in
her life with cancer and with Strokes
dealing with racism in south Louisiana
growing up
it was important for me to learn about
God through my difficulties for example
rather than let those difficulties turn
me away from him
many times people put a barrier between
them and God because they can't make
sense of the things that are happening
in their own lives
and so they project anger towards God
and at the same time deny their own
belief in him and do away with this
natural disposition that every one of us
has to believe in him so they're
intellectual barriers certainly there
are experiential barriers
but I think that one of the beautiful
things about Islam is Clarity uh there
is an explanation
for
his existence there's an explanation for
our existence there's an explanation for
the existence of difficulties in trial
and explanation for the existence of
desires and distractions
and it all comes together so beautifully
and coherently in Islam and so
I think that for many of us we want to
be our own Gods you know and ultimately
we create and fashion gods in ways that
allow us to still be the ultimate
determiners of our own fates of Our Own
story
and that's very unfulfilling when you
fail at your own plan but when you
realize that there is one who was all
knowing
that there is one who is all wise
you actually find peace in submitting
yourself to him and so submitting your
will to him submitting your desires
submitting your own fate to him becomes
actually an experience of Liberation
because you trust the one that you're
submitting to you trust his knowledge
over yours you trust his wisdom over
yours
and that gives you a lot of peace and
then you have direct access to them you
pray to him you call upon him you
supplicate
and
everything in your life suddenly has
meaning you know in our faith
everything is about intention and
there's an intentionality even behind
the most seemingly most mundane actions
a morsel of food in the mouth of your
spouse your family is looked at as a
great charity the way that you enter
into a place and exit out of a place
what foot you step in what foot you step
out with there's an intentionality
there's a word of remembrance that's
spoken
there's a word of Praise before and
after you engage in any action there are
things that you say before you eat
before you sleep there is meaning even
to your sleep one of the great
Companions of the Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him he said that I
seek the reward for my sleep just as I
seek the reward for my prayer because
you sleep to refresh yourself so that
you can once again do great things and
the intentionality behind that allows
even the sleep to be rewardable you eat
to nourish yourself so that you can do
great things you seek to be in a
position of Independence and of being
sustained so that you can sustain others
so the prophet peace be upon Him says
for example that the upper hand is
better than the lower hand the upper
hand is the giving hand the lower hand
is the receiving hand so to seek a
position where you can help other people
everything becomes intentional and
there's no such thing as you know
something that is meaningless and
without purpose so every Pursuit is
ultimately a pursuit of God and when you
pursue God sincerely then he rewards you
not just with Paradise in the afterlife
but he rewards you with a great sense of
Serenity and self-satisfaction here you
mentioned part of the struggle growing
up was having a parent your mom
who was sick what do you remember
about your mom what are some happy
pleasant memories
so my parents were well my father I
thank God is still alive
um my mother was a Pious woman a
beautiful woman
a righteous woman a woman who was known
for treating everyone with a great deal
of love and respect she was a poet she
used to write poetry about oppressed
peoples around the world
from her homeland in Palestine to the
genocide in Bosnia she followed every
conflict before social media and poured
her heart into it she was a woman of
great charity
so when I think back to my mom growing
up she was known for her smile my mom
was always smiling and in fact every
picture of her she's smiling and at her
funeral you know people talked about her
smile that she would smile at everyone
and that was kind of her thing so if you
were left out of a gathering she was
smiling at you and she'd kind of welcome
you in
I remember my mom to be content she was
a woman of prayer and a woman of
contentment so I used to see her in her
prayer clothes all the time in fact when
I think back to her growing up I think
of her more in her prayer clothes than
in her normal clothes because that's how
often she was engaged in prayer
and I think of her
um making sure that everyone was
included in a conversation so she was
very interesting
and that she had several Strokes
um and each one of those Strokes
impaired one of her senses to some
extent so she was partially deaf because
of one stroke
and she'd be sitting in a gathering and
she'd be pretty quiet with a big smile
on her face very serene
and she would tell me you know
alhamdulillah which means thank thank
God all praise be to God that I can't
hear because uh I can tell when people
are gossiping when people are saying
negative things around me about other
people because she says even the look on
people's faces changes so it's it was
really interesting because she was that
spiritually rooted and and deep that she
said like you could see on the looks on
people's faces when they started to
speak ill about other people that their
faces would change that the Nate their
demeanor would change and she said I
would actually praise the Lord
that I couldn't engage in those
conversations and that I wasn't sinful
for hearing them and what she would do
is what what people said
at her funeral which was really
beautiful to me it was very comforting
to me and I took it as a life mission
that if you were new to a place or if
you were kind of in the corner and not
not known to other people in the
community and you felt left out she was
the one that literally would look around
the room
and she'd see who was standing in the
corner and who was new to the community
or new to whatever place and she'd go
and try to include that person in the
Gathering so even when she had impaired
speech and impaired hearing uh with her
smile and with her warmth she was able
to welcome people uh wherever that was
and so the amount of people that came
to her funeral and the stories that I
continue to hear till this day 15 years
later after her passing away
of people that said you know no one ever
treated me the way your mother treated
me and she connected that to God
so that was actually part of my faith
Journey when I think of great people
when I think of people of faith
she's the first person that comes to my
mind because
despite her challenges she was always
the greatest person that you would meet
to anyone that met her and that knew her
would say I'd never I've never met
anyone that kind that was her reputation
and she was deeply empathetic she would
shed tears over people that she had no
connection to this is again before
social media before you know the the
heavy exposure that we have to people in
Conflict zones
she had to engage every single human
being in her life in a deep and profound
way because she had a profound
connection to God and she believed that
that was her calling
and none of her challenges made her
bitter in fact they only made her more
connected to God and they only made her
a better person until the last breath
that she took
do you miss her
yeah
there I mean yes absolutely but I
I feel like everything I do is an
extension of her
so you try to carry what she stood for
absolutely as part of yourself the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
that when a person passes away there are
only three things that continue to
benefit them that continue to extend
them
a continuous charity
or a piece of knowledge that continues
to benefit people
or a righteous child that prays for them
and I want to be that child that prays
for her but also does charity in her
name extends her charity extends what
she taught me by being the person that
she was
to everyone around me and there's some
times where I don't feel like getting
out of bed sometimes where I don't feel
like doing for myself but I actually
feel like doing for her so everything in
my life that I try to do
I try to make it an extension of her and
um
that's been my calling and you know I
believe I'll meet her again
I believe I'll be with her again
I believe that everything I do that is
good will be of benefit to her
and I believe that it would make her
proud
and so as much as I miss her
uh as much as I am
fueled to do for her and so I continue
that and that's kind of become part of
my life it's been my life story
as a child and as an adult it's been
sort of the centerpiece of my life to do
things that extend her
and ultimately in the process hopefully
benefit me because I I believe that
she's a woman who I pray is destined for
paradise and I want to do the things
that would get me there too
what did you learn about death
about life from
losing her
I feel like the facade of the material
world
was made evident to me at a very young
age you know most children grow up
and
their parents want to protect them from
everything and and I felt that too you
know my my mother wanted to downplay her
own tragedy so that me and my brother
could live a fruitful and fulfilling
life my father wanted to protect us
from
the hardship of her life so that we
could live fulfilling lives he was he'd
often be the only father on a field trip
even though he was a distinguished
Professor I mean he was a busy man
he he was a very busy man but he tried
to show up at a field trip and tried to
make our lives as normal as possible
but
in the process we always understood that
there was more to life than
what other children were seeing it as
and now I know that as an adult there's
more to life than what other adults see
it as the material world
disappointed early on so that we could
see beyond it and I often tell people
that you know
there are many that grow up in tragedy
orphan children
um refugees
that
grow up and do incredible things because
they immediately see past
the
facade they see through all of the
material Promises of this world the
deception of it
and that you can choose to be bitter as
a result of that or you can choose to
be better
and I think that for me I had to
consciously make that decision that I
was going to live a life
of prayer I was going to live a life of
Charity I was going to live a life of
commitment
and
in that process
invest in something that's greater
invest in something that doesn't
disappoint
and so I believe in God I believe in the
hereafter
and I believe that God will not let any
trial
or effort in this life go to waste
without it being repaid in the Hereafter
and so I work towards that and so life
and death
I understood existence to be
Transcendent early on that if I believe
that there was nothing to life except
for life I would be a very bitter person
but because
I know that there is more to it than
this
I'm able to uh exist in it
without being depressed by it
existence is Transcendence
what happens after we die
after
the
material instantiation
uh Fades away
so the Quran tells us
that God brought us from the darkness of
the womb
into this life
you were nothing but a dirty drop of
fluid and you became this fully
proportioned human being from the
darkness of the womb you come into this
life
you experience it and then you go to the
darkness of the Grave only to be
resurrected once again
and that we are
Souls
with bodies not bodies with souls and
there's a huge difference between those
two things
this is the vehicle that contains us
here
this is the material world that we
encounter here
but we are not this
and this is not our entire existence and
so the soul continues this is a life in
which
we
seek to worship Him
and seek to live in accordance with the
purpose that he has set out for us
and after we pass away our soul
continues onwards
either to reward or to punishment or to
a mixture of both but it's a it's a
realm of accountability
and hopefully it's a realm of reward uh
should we exist in a way that he wants
us to exist
so he said that you can look to God for
wisdom to make sense of the world
there's a lot of stuff to us humans
that's difficult to make sense of
um like you losing your mother
there's a lot of Cruelty in the world
there's a lot of suffering in the world
uh what
wisdom uh
have you been able to find uh from God
about about why there is suffering in
the world why there's cruelty you know
there's a thing that I wanted to ask God
about why he allows hunger and War and
poverty but I was afraid he might ask me
the same question
God has certainly given us enough food
there's enough food in the world for
everyone to have a 3200 calorie diet a
day
God has certainly given us enough
guidance uh for us to not inflict on
each other the cruelty that we inflict
when we look to the world around us
first and foremost we have to have a
sense of accountability we are
accountable for our own actions we don't
blame God for the evil of man that's one
but at the same time we understand that
God and his wisdom allows for certain
outcomes that we cannot Encompass with
our own
and that to isolate these incidents
and to try to make sense of them is no
different than a baby in the womb
that doesn't understand the world that
it's coming into and trying to explain
to that baby that hasn't yet developed
its own senses and its own perception of
this world
what is happening to it right you know I
often think of the example of a child
and
you know having
been at this point now through the
experience of
Parenthood I'm still learning I'm just
going into having a teenager uh with
three kids
and being a softy for my kids you know
when you have to tell your child that
they can't have something that they
really really want
and that child thinks you hate them at
some point you know because why are you
stopping me from
putting this toy in my mouth
and choking myself they don't get it
right but at the same time you prevent
them out of love they're not in a
position to understand that you're
preventing them out of love
and to isolate these incidents with God
and to say the wisdom what's the wisdom
uh you're trying to make sense of a
pixel when you can't see the bigger
picture
your mind is not at a place where you
can make sense of the bigger picture you
haven't seen the bigger picture
and so
for him to even explain to us every
incidence
uh would completely defeat the purpose
of putting your trust in him so
we believe in a god that is
all-encompassing in his knowledge and
wisdom
that gives us and Islam is very PR you
know specific by the way that there is
what God tells us to do and there's what
God allows to happen
so what God tells us to do in terms of
the road map towards good and then what
God allows to happen in his Divine
wisdom that no outcome can escape him
but at the same time we are accountable
for our own actions and our own Deeds
so when you come to someone and say you
know why did God allow this to happen to
this person
I can't rationalize that for you because
my understanding is relegated to the
immediate experience in front of me
but if I know God and if I learn about
God
then
I don't have to make sense of the plan
but I can tell you that I trust the
planner
and I think that that's where peace is
found
you know a lot of times you look for the
light at the end of the tunnel what's
the light at the end of the tunnel in
Islam there's emphasis on God and the
Hereafter because to try to make sense
of
ah Divine decree and why certain things
happen in this world without the
existence of a God or without the
existence of a hereafter
will always fail you so the existence of
a god that is all-knowing what we don't
know I know what you don't know that
understands what we don't understand the
existence of a God who is not subject to
our constrictions
and the existence of a Hereafter where
all things find recourse where there is
divine recourse
allows for this world to be situated
within the existence of something
greater and not treated in isolation so
when you're trying to treat an incidence
of this world in isolation you're going
to fail and when you try to treat
existence in this world and of this
world in isolation you're also going to
fail and so the emphasis is the belief
in God
a god that is not limited like you are
and a belief in the Hereafter that is
not limited like this life
and so everything continues onwards and
there is divine recourse for everything
each and everything you know the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon it
mentions that
on the day of judgment a person who
lived the most difficult of lives will
be dipped into Paradise one time and
will be told have you ever seen any
sadness any hardship now when you think
about the most difficult life some of
the commentators in Islam they said that
this is perhaps referring to the prophet
job
Ayub peace be upon him because job lived
obviously a life of great difficulty but
that a person who lived a very hard life
would be dipped into Paradise one time
and just with a dip be asked have you
ever seen any hardship have you ever
seen any misery and that person would
say what is sadness what is hardship
what is misery now if you don't believe
in the Hereafter if you don't believe in
anything beyond this life then the
recourse has to happen in this life and
because we see so many people pass
through this life
without recourse of Cruelty Without
recourse of suffering then we're forced
to try to make sense of it and if you
are someone who believes that this
entire world came into existence through
Randomness that were just an existence
of
random atoms that collide with each
other and that all of this comes
together out of nothing
then how can you put your trust in
anything that is greater
so as a you know you asked me as a child
of a parent who suffered
I believe that every moment that my
mother
suffered
that she will be rewarded that she will
be elevated that all of that made her or
contributed to the beautiful person that
she was and will contribute to the
beautiful reward that she receives and
the recourse is certain to me as a
believer in that
so the right approach to making sense of
the world
especially making sense of suffering and
cruelty is that of humility
that we as humans
cannot possibly understand fully
absolutely in fact in the Quran it's
very interesting when God creates Adam
the Angels say to God
are you going to create
uh a race or a species that will spill
blood and cause corruption
and God says to the angels in response
to that question I know that which you
don't know
so even the angels have to Humble
themselves for a moment the Angels who
adore God who love God who worship Him
who obey him unconditionally they are
told
by God I know that which you don't know
and what we extract from that with many
of the early interpretations extract
from that is that
God knows that there are human beings
that will come out of this Enterprise of
humanity that make the entire existence
of it worth it and so just as yes there
will be criminals and corrupt ones
there will be prophets and beautiful
people that come out of this and sages
and saints that come out of this that
show that a human being
who unlike an angel who has no choice
but to worship God an angel has no sense
of will no sense of choice an angel is
created to worship and has no desires a
human being who has the choice of desire
and worship the choice of righteousness
and wickedness that there are human
beings who will choose worship and
righteousness that will choose charity
over cruelty
that will choose service and choose
dedication and devotion
over death and destruction that there
are human beings that will in fact
Ascend the angels in rank because they
will live lives where they choose that
capacity that part of themselves
and they lean into that and worship God
lovingly and Obey him you see in some of
the sages in Islam Scholars they
describe this as saying that the human
being has the capacity
to be anywhere from an animal to an
angel or even worse to be a devil you
know to an angel not in the sense that
we ever actually become Angels or become
animals but that an animal you know for
the most part seeks its desires over
everything doesn't really think about
you know many of the things that we are
supposed to calculate as human beings
doesn't think about which territory it's
infringing upon or you know how much of
its appetite it should fulfill it simply
exists to fulfill its appetite and that
many human beings simply exist to
fulfill their appetite and they choose
that over worship or reason or anything
that is greater just
they literally take their selves as gods
in that sense and their selves have no
limitation on appetite so they just keep
filling that appetite and filling that
appetite and filling that appetite
whereas
a human being can also go to the extent
of choosing something greater
and disciplining their desires
disciplining themselves because they're
seeking a greater reward you know we
know many people that achieve great
things
in the worldly sense
because they choose to study over sleep
for example
they choose to exert themselves towards
their careers towards their education
because they believe that ultimately the
outcome of those Pursuits are more
rewarding than the immediate fulfillment
of their desires so as Believers we
choose that love of God and we choose
that outcome that we seek and we
discipline ourselves to where we can
even Ascend past the angels and rank now
of course I said we can go as low as an
animal or as low as a devil
and we have tyrants
past and present and future as well
that can become satanic in their nature
because they allow their desires to take
such control over them that they not
only worship them but that every other
existing being around them
simply becomes a piece of their own
puzzle and pursuit of their own lordship
and their own satisfaction and they will
kill they will discard not because you
know and I always say this it's not that
tyrants
necessarily like killing people it's not
people's lives uh pose somewhat of an
you know an indifference to them they're
indifferent to people's existence and so
you become
either an object for or against me and
so they're willing to discard
children discard people discard the
rights of others because they ultimately
have chosen that the greatest pursuit of
themselves is the maximum position of
power
and a place to where they can fulfill
what they want to of themselves without
any limits and every everyone else
becomes either a threat or an
opportunity in that regard so we can be
Devils we can be Angelic like we could
be animals
we're somewhere on that spectrum and
every moment contains a set of choices
you can make absolutely every single
moment contains a set of choices and
that's where the intentionality comes in
right so the prophet Muhammad as peace
be upon Him says that I saw a person
strolling in Paradise because he removed
something harmful from the road
uh he tells us about a woman that lived
the life and prostitution but that
repented to God when she was thirsty one
day and she saw a dog that was also
thirsty and she said that I was thirsty
and God gave me water so I'm going to
choose to give water to that Thirsty Dog
and God enters her into Paradise as a
result of that
sometimes the small moments with a small
sincere deed
can have a huge impact on a person's
trajectory so every moment is a moment
of choices and
when we choose
belief righteousness a pursuit of
something greater than we find ways to
turn things that are otherwise mundane
and to
miraculous acts right where we can we
can choose God over ourselves and in the
process choose a better fate for
ourselves
how difficult is the process of knowing
understanding what is the righteous
action
of
knowing what it means to be a good man
or a good woman
well the truth has consequences so don't
seek out the truth unless you're willing
to abide by what you find so a lot of
people want to mold
their journey in accordance with a
predetermined Pursuit that they already
have and so when they approach religion
they approach it like another product
you know there was a uh an article that
was actually written by a rabbi I've
spoken about this in several sermons it
was called the Allure of narcissistic
spirituality the Allure of narcissistic
spirituality where he talks about
you know how religion becomes just
another product of your own self
adoration and worship to where you only
approach religion to the extent that it
gives you
more happiness in the worldly sense you
only approach of it what is therapeutic
so it becomes just as
secular
in its nature as any other practice of
meditation or whatever it may be or some
other product and it kind of mentions
you know how uh he he took that from a
person that is praying in a temple and a
guy walks into the temple and bumps into
him and then he curses the guy out so he
didn't see his behavior towards that
person as uh part of his trajectory of
worship he just saw his being Godly as
the worship that he was engaged in the
truth has
consequences the truth has circumstances
that are required of you actions that
are required of you that may be somewhat
inconvenient so you have to be willing
to engage in a sincere Pursuit Of Truth
and look for Truth for what it is
and not simply look for comfort and
convenience
and when you engage in that journey of
wanting to know
you have to engage it thoroughly
and sincerely and try your best to
remove any bias I think that's what
makes the the religion of Islam such a
phenomenon for people that with all the
islamophobia and the bigotry towards it
still the fastest growing religion in
the United States and the fastest
growing religion in the world to know
that's not all birth rate
yeah we have a lot of kids but
um many people you know you met someone
just before we started this interview
many people in fact in a post-9 11 world
solve what they saw of Islam in the
media
and they actually you know went and
checked out copies of the Quran and
started to read about the religion and
in their sincere Pursuit Of Truth ended
up embracing religion that they believed
was the greatest source of Destruction
in the world and now it's the greatest
source of peace for them in their own
existence in their own lives and so you
have to be willing to engage in a
sincere pursuit of wanting to know
and then be willing to engage in sincere
commitment after you know otherwise the
heart rests and so there's a process in
the Quran talks about this of making the
heart like fertile soil towards truth so
you have a sincere Pursuit but then at
some point if you come to know and then
you ignore what you come to know then
the heart rests and it becomes harder to
recognize it the second time around the
third time around and so when people
come to me and they say you know
I'm looking for something I'm looking
for I'm looking for God I'm looking for
my purpose the first thing I tell them
as I say listen
what you need to do is if you're really
looking for God in your and you believe
in God and there are often people that
say I believe in God but I don't know
where to go with this right I know that
there's something greater in Islam we
call that the fitra a natural
disposition towards the belief in the
existence of God
um but where do I go from here you know
what do I do now and I say the first
thing you need to do is
you need to sincerely say oh God guide
me to the truth
call upon God sincerely say I'm calling
upon you alone and I'm asking you to
guide me to the truth show me what it is
right
and that's the heart function
then you need to actually investigate
and try to suspend bias right
investigate the world's religions
investigate the claims to Truth uh
investigate use you know rational
inquiry to the extent that the heart
becomes satisfied
and
suspend bias and you'll be surprised and
so for a lot of people
they come to me and they say you know
this this about Islam I'm like look I'm
if you're just going to talk to me about
what you've seen of Islam in the media
if you were serious about it you know if
you're serious about it then
uh you're not simply going to be
satisfied with
the highly edited images and distorted
facts that come towards you about this
religion right
what are you looking for right are you
are you looking for a scapegoat Islam
poses a threat to many people right are
you looking for a scapegoat are you
looking for the big bad scary foreign
enemy
or are you looking at
a religion that one-fourth of the world
adheres to and if one-fourth of us were
bad the world would not exist right so
are you looking towards this religion
that one-fourth of the world adheres to
are you going to read about the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him are you going
to read the Quran yourself are you going
to investigate for yourself uh what it
is that this faith has to offer and find
in it a great sense of of of wisdom a
great sense of beauty a great sense of
Truth
and I think that for for a lot of people
you know they they find that Islam has
such a beautiful combination of the
intellectual proofs as well as the
spiritual experiences that often combine
uh what people seek in the Western and
the Eastern religion so I had an
interesting two weeks
uh two weeks in a row
um this was August two weeks in a row I
had someone who converted to Islam
that went from being that started off as
a Methodist went from being a Methodist
to being a Buddhist to being a Muslim so
two weeks in a row I had a Methodist
turn Buddhist turn Muslim great journey
yeah I I called my my Methodist uh
friends I have a lot of Methodist
Pastors in the city that I work with and
I said what's going on here man you're
sending people on to this interesting
journey of Buddhism and then Islam but
both of them had a very similar story
which is that they had sought in
Buddhism for example the
you know some of the meditative
practices that are found that that
really Western religion which has been
dominated by capitalism and dominated by
by very material things and uh can be
very unfulfilling they found that in
some of the Eastern philosophies and the
meditative practices and then they came
to Islam and it combined you know their
their belief in sort of the abrahamic
way it merged their belief in one God
and the prophets like Abraham and Moses
and Jesus peace be upon them all with a
a deep tradition
of meditative practices of consciousness
of connection to God on a regular basis
and they found that to be very
fulfilling both intellectually and
spiritually and so I was like that's
interesting you know two people in two
weeks that went through that Journey so
I think Islam is is very wholesome
comprehensive when people actually
approach it with humility and uh and and
appreciate what it has to offer
as you mentioned uh
in the minds of some Americans after 9
11 the religion of Islam was associated
with
maybe you could say evil in the world
yeah maybe you can say uh terrorism how
can you respond to this Association how
does it make you feel first of all as a
devout Muslim yourself and
um how can you overcome it personally
how can you overcome it as a community
and as a religious leader
it's interesting because 9 11 now we're
talking over 21 years ago
you know there's people born after 9 11.
it's great you get to talk to them all
the time yeah so when I'm talking to
Young Muslims I'm talking about Post 9
11 Post 9 11 they're like I didn't I was
born in 2005. what are you talking about
Post 9 11 I'm like well you know I
remember being a teenager I remember
being in high school when this happened
right so a lot of us that experienced
911 as high school lures or as college
students and remember distinctly what it
was like to be a Muslim pre-9 11 and
Post 9 11. uh we can relate to that
experience and we could we could
identify that juncture you know very
clearly and talk about it and speak to
the change in the perceptions of Islam
that happened here in the United States
and around the world but a lot of young
people are born into that reality and
are experiencing the aftermath of it
and um you know unfortunately have to
deal with the bigotry that has uh not
just you know taken greater shape in
media constructions of Islam but also
policies right a lot of the civil
liberties of the Muslim Community were
taken away from us you read about the
Patriot Act you read about the
securitization of the Muslim Community
and some of the unfair practices that
have been engaged by the Bush
Administration the Obama Administration
the Trump Administration and continue
into the Biden Administration uh
International islamophobia and so
the hatred of Muslims and the bigotry
that is wielded against
Muslims on the basis of this idea that
we are a barbaric people not
ascribe to a religion of hate and
violence
has had immediate consequences for us no
matter where we are in terms of our age
and in terms of our experience we We
have dealt with that in different ways
now
the association of Islam to terrorism is
a lazy Association
it's one that ignores both
The History of Violence
as well as its everyday occurrence
you know we're good for how many mass
shootings a year
once when's the last time you heard of a
Muslim carrying out a mass shooting in
America right how many of those mass
shootings if you were to scrub the
social media what 400 500 mass shootings
a year
if you were to scrub the social media of
some of those that carried out those
shootings you know we're good for one or
two idiots a year right you know it's
unfortunate that you're gonna have
people that that carry out despicable
acts of violence
but when we as Muslims hear someone in
the media say terrorism has been ruled
out as a possibility
while the blood is still on the floor of
that Walmart we already know that the
police chief just said that that wasn't
a Muslim don't worry you know there was
no Kari the guy or an Isis guy
um it was it was one of our own right
and so it's it's become frankly
ridiculous because the association of
violence with Islam
uh is one that is used to actually uh
carry out acts of violence against
Muslims worldwide it justifies bad
policy towards Muslims worldwide and
then in the United States and it's just
factually so lazy there was a study just
about how the media gives more attention
to acts of violence done by Muslims and
immediately uh stamps it with Islam up
to 300 percent more than it will with
another act of violence carried out in
the name of anything else so you don't
hear about the acts of violence that are
carried out by others you don't hear
about the religion of the perpetrators
you don't associate terrorism with
actions frankly of State terrorism you
know when governments launch chemical
attacks or drone weddings
and do so while explicitly dehumanizing
the people just because they do so
with the government apparatus doesn't
make it any less terroristic than if
it's a lone person that goes out and
commits an act of violence trying to
achieve a political goal
so the association is lazy historically
speaking the Crusades I grew up in
Louisiana I saw Clan rallies ku klux
klan rallies my whole life and people
said well that's a thing of the past
well guess what you know we see many
semblances many acts that are carried
out with the same vitriol that was
generated by the Ku Klux Klan
we have people standing in front of our
mosques that belong to right wing hate
militias carrying
AR-15s talking about wanting to inflict
harm on Muslims I have been to
Christchurch New Zealand and buried the
victims of a white supremacist terrorist
who was inspired by the political
rhetoric here in the United States in
his own words in his Manifesto to go and
kill 50 innocent people in Christchurch
New Zealand one of the most peaceful
cities in the world
and by the way Lex I mean it's really
interesting like with Christ Church
you know the man wanted and I won't even
say his name
but his next Target after the two
mosques had he not been stopped was to
go to a Muslim daycare so what drives
someone
to dehumanize people to that extent that
he was willing to go to a daycare and
murder a bunch of kids because he saw
them as a demographic threat to
civilization so Muslims are terrorized
because they are falsely depicted as
terrorists Muslims suffer domestically
and globally because of this false
Association It's a lazy Association
and when someone comes around and says
well
um fine not all Muslims are terrorists
but all terrorists are Muslims I say
that
you clearly don't read statistics
whether we're talking about the 20th
century and I'm a student of history and
I believe you are as well all the isms
World War One World War II had nothing
to do with religion certainly nothing to
do with Islam fascism uh Soviet atheism
right many of these systems where people
were murdered in the millions Nazism uh
the Holocaust Rwanda Cambodia I can go
on and on the rohingya Today the
greatest atrocity towards the oyers
where is Islam fit in all of this people
do horrible things
they stamp it with religion at times
but the only group of people that seem
to suffer after an act of violence is
committed are Muslims because any act of
violence that is committed by a Muslim
will immediately be blamed on Islam and
two billion people will have to carry
the burden of the act of a single
perpetrator
and
just to reiterate
in case the numbers are not known you
mentioned Christ Church those are two
mosque shootings
oh 51 people killed and 40 were injured
in New Zealand yeah
so it's uh
it's hate manifesting itself and and
then uh actual human suffering and
destruction
absolutely is there similarities between
uh anti-Semitism and anti-muslim Hate
so is there something deeper to say
about hate in general here that is
beyond just particularly hate towards
Muslims absolutely look
um in Pittsburgh the synagogue shooting
the perpetrator particularly targeted
targeted that
synagogue because Tree of Life synagogue
is life synagogue 11 killed six wounded
in 2018.
because
he believed that they were taking in
Syrian refugees or supporting Syrian
Muslim refugees
you think about that
the San Diego synagogue shooting that
took place shortly after he went to a
mosque and then he went to a synagogue
um
look the idea of
scapegoating minority populations
and attributing to them
a disproportionate sense of power and a
nefarious element where they can't be
trusted
and unless we wipe them out
then they're going to wipe us out
underlies many of the bigotries that
exist I mean look um after Trump
announced his Muslim ban there was a
shooting in Canada an attack in Canada
on a mosque in Quebec where six people
were killed
the shooter explicitly said that the
reason why he went to that mosque in
Quebec and shot dead six Muslim
worshipers was because he was afraid
that because of the ban on Syrian
refugees in the United States they would
come to Canada and he didn't want them
to feel welcomed in Canada
so there is a connection
and I think it's when you are able to
dehumanize large groups of people
and attribute a nefarious element to
them
then unfortunately in a world that's
becoming more and more polarized where
people are able to construct their
entire world views based on an algorithm
that their social media caters to
you're going to have
some of these attacks happen and there's
going to be an unfortunate connection
between them
so what I what I tell people is that you
know I think with all of these people
that shoot up synagogues and shoot up
mosques and even before that actually
the
Charleston South Carolina shooting at an
AME Church
you know
when he went there
he actually said that before he murdered
nine worshipers in that church
he was taken aback by how nice they were
to him he sat there for two hours before
he turned a gun on
many people who were over the age of 80
years old
and murdered Them In Cold Blood
so this is what I talk about when I say
that as human beings we have the
propensity unfortunately uh
to become worse than Devils or we can
choose
to be angelic
when we choose worship and righteousness
over ourselves
so that's a spiritual crisis as well and
a crisis of meaning and emptiness
where I think
people are willing to inflict great pain
on others when they can't make sense of
their pain in their own lives
I'd like to try to figure out together
with you sort of um
a way out
to try to decrease the amount of hate in
the world but maybe it's useful to talk
about the BBC documentary that
um it's kind of interesting that people
should check out it's called United
States of hate Muslims under attack and
you um you appear in that you have
conversations with people who are uh
anti-muslim and it's I believe most of
it takes place here in Dallas yeah and
can you just tell me about this uh
little documentary about that time what
it was like to interact what was the
group in the documentary and what was
like to interact with them you know in
the very beginning of um the rise
of at that time actually Ted Cruz Donald
Trump like when when islamophobia
uh was at the center of many of the
presidential candidates campaigns at the
time so this must have been 2015 yes
2015.
um the mayor of Irving at the time Beth
Van Dyne who is now a congresswoman
had put out the idea
that Muslims were operating at Sharia
Court in Irving Texas
and suddenly there was hysteria because
again there's the idea that Muslims are
here to dominate Muslims are here to
overthrow everything that you have
um in the United States there was a
hysteria here
and it was unfortunate because
um what it Unleashed you know especially
with the national discourse at the time
again the presidential campaign you know
Donald Trump says I think Islam hates us
when he uses those words I think Islam
hates us
when Ted Cruz suggests that Muslim
neighborhoods could be patrolled or
should be patrolled
and then you have the Irving mayor
saying that one of the most populated
cities with Muslims in America they're
operating under an alternative uh legal
and Alternate legal system and
funny enough the year before that she'd
come to the mosque and she praised the
diversity of Irving and she was talking
about how welcome she felt in the mosque
and the next thing we know you have
these crazy white supremacist groups
openly white supremacists that affiliate
themselves with
the clan and others
protesting regularly in front of our
mosques with their AR-15s and
um telling people to go back home and
I'm like I'm from New Orleans I'm not
planning to move back to New Orleans I'm
home we're we're home we're good you
know we're staying put
and we refuse to be intimidated
but then when the Syrian refugee crisis
is unfolding as well
Dallas has been one of the more popular
destinations if you will I'm not talking
about it like a vacation destination but
where a lot of refugees have come to
just because of the infrastructure that
we have set up here to receive refugees
and so that hysteria
was an unfortunate perfect combustion of
the national discourse with the local
discourse with the incoming refugees
and we would do all sorts of Welcome
Refugee events and we do that you know
and and we don't only do that for Muslim
refugees by the way there are refugees
from other parts of the world as well
um but we would host events at our
mosques you know to welcome refugees to
help integrate them into the community
to do things for them so you have these
armed protests happening right and it's
horrible because
think about the trauma to the children
that are hearing about tree of life and
hearing about some of these other
incidents that are unfolding and really
one of the first communities I was
targeted was the Sikh community in
Madison that was one of the first
shootings and then the AME Church
Charleston
and then you just had tons of places of
worship being targeted right so they're
seeing this unfold and they're seeing
these guns in front of their mosques and
the result
to many as well I just don't want to get
shot I don't want to go to the mosque I
don't want to have this happen to me
so I you know when BBC reached out and
said we want to do a documentary about
this uh unfortunately Dallas was the
only place in America where you had
regular armed groups in front of our
mosques it was happening around the
country infrequently but here it was
happening every week so the BBC reached
out and said we want to interview you I
said we've got this idea we want to put
you we want to take you to a park and
have you meet one of the protesters uh
who's been wielding his gun outside your
mosque and talked to him
and it was really interesting because
they'd interviewed him before meeting me
and the things that he was able to utter
before meeting me and before meeting
Syrian refugees
uh was just awful I mean the most
dehumanizing rhetoric that you can
imagine
but then at the park
he meets me talks to me he meets a
Syrian refugee family
one of the girls whose leg had been
blown off in an airstrike
and he said I feel like an idiot I mean
he expressed all sorts of regret
and was teary-eyed
that he could dehumanize people the way
that he was and so my whole thing was
and is come inside the mosque put your
gun down
disarm yourself and learn
and you'll be surprised what you'll walk
away with
and only took one meeting with him
um so completely
uh shift
his worldview at the time
which
was made up of heroes and villains the
Muslims unfortunately being the villains
that had to be wiped off the face of the
Earth so that the Earth could continue
so that was uh that was an interesting
documentary and it was an interesting
social experiment
uh what's it feel like to have
all these
people that hate you
and others in the community people you
love
with guns
threatening violence
basically that we don't want you here in
this country on this Earth
um
it's not nice
it's not great I mean it's um
it's definitely a challenge but look
there are challenges that we face as as
Muslims
um being in the United States being in a
hostile climate there are different
types of challenges and uh I think what
we've had to do as a Muslim Community
is see beyond both the guns and the
roses and think about who we are first
because frankly
uh
islamophobia exists in different forms
and from different sides
and we try to use this as an opportunity
to instill in our young people
not just the sense of belonging but a
sense of purpose
ah
do not be intimidated
and in fact show them the best of your
Islam live your life because at the end
of the day
the goal that is sought through
intimidation is silence
and so we have to carry ourselves as
proud American Muslims we don't have to
impress anyone
and we don't need to relinquish an iota
of our faith
to coexist with anyone uh we are
satisfied with who we are we don't we
don't see a contradiction
between
our place of residence and our religion
our nationality our religion we don't
see that as a problem right so that's a
that's something for them to work out
not for you to work out that's what I
would tell young Muslims that continue
to live your faith fully
and demonstrate the beauty of it and do
not let the ugliness of the world
consume you
but for those young Muslims what would
you say how they should feel towards the
people that hate them
the natural human
there's a desire still to have anger to
have
a resentment to have hate back at the
people that hate you
the Quran says respond to that which is
evil with that which is better and you
will find that
sometimes your enemy will become your
close friend
so respond with that which is better
doesn't mean be passive sometimes there
needs to be a demonstration of strength
sometimes there needs to be a
demonstration of uh
ignoring a people altogether
But ultimately you can't let the way
people treat you shape who you're going
to be in the world
and so that's why I say we have to look
beyond the guns on the Roses we have to
look Beyond
the hostility of our enemies and the
temporary and opportunistic embrace of
some of those who claim to be our allies
and be us and treat the world and treat
the people of this world in accordance
with your standards
not with theirs so don't teach them
you know or don't let them teach you bad
character you teach them good character
so live your life and and uh live your
faith beautifully
and let people see the beauty of it
through your through your being and do
not let their ugliness
consume you but at the same time
sometimes you got to give people room to
express frustration
to to say that this is unacceptable to
have demonstrations of strength
and I think that those things don't have
to all contradict each other
yeah what do you think about these kinds
of protests are not allowed in many
parts of the world what do you think
about
one of the most do you directly
personally painful manifestations of the
first amendment of The People's right to
freedom of speech into protest to say
hateful things
uh you've been at the receiving end
of the worst of it
what what what do you feel about this
particular Freedom that uh that's at the
core of the founding of this country
look I think that you have to take it
away from the text and look at it within
reality let's be real uh would Muslims
be able to protest in front of churches
with guns on a weekly basis in this
country I don't think so so that's a
deep pragmatically speaking there's a
hypocrisy too what's major hypocrisy
major hypocrisy see free speech
is an ideal that is weaponized against
the Muslim Community and against other
communities
in such a hypocritical way you know you
take for example some countries in
Europe you know let's kind of move away
from this and look at the hypocrisy of
uh a place like France where the
caricaturing and the portrayal of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him in
derogatory ways will be used as the
Hallmark of free speech but
Muslims that will caricature uh macron
or challenge some of the values of
France the supposed and trying values of
France
will end up in prison and end up
deported and so here in the United
States there's a great hypocrisy I don't
think that uh places of worship should
have armed protesters in front of them I
think that that poses a security risk I
think that it's not okay
um
and I think that free speech is
weaponized against the Muslim Community
and often is held up as this great value
but really to attain very lowly things
and uh is often to our detriments
yeah just even watching that documentary
it's hard to put into words but somehow
that
does not capture
what maybe the founders intended
right what uh what I would see is the
great idea of the freedom of speech
um
I don't know what the solution to that
is
I think taking it outside of words maybe
that requires a community a cultural
pressure to be better
uh
so it's not about the law it's more
about just the cultural pressure what
isn't isn't okay because there's
something deeply wrong about that kind
of hate
uh yeah because it was dehumanizing
other people there here in America
that there are Americans
yeah I mean it's it's we have to
interrogate
the foundations of our country when our
country is in such turmoil and such
chaos uh no country in the world has the
mass shootings that we have no country
in the world has
some of the polarization that we have we
have to interrogate that and say what it
is that we're doing wrong that's leading
to that
and I think again that it's it's
reaching a point where it's
unsustainable
um if we don't do better
and try to solve
some of the Rifts right now that exist
in our society
then we're going to end up in you know
in a place where we might we may not be
able to climb out of this
what do you think about you mentioned
the Muslim ban what do you think about
executive order
13769 titled protecting the nation from
foreign terrorist entry into the United
States often referred to as the Muslim
ban or the Trump travel ban it was an
executive order by President Trump that
was in effect from January 27 2017.
for just a few months until March 6
2017.
um
what was this executive order and what
was its effect on your life and on the
life of the Muslim Community and just
the life of Americans well it was
disgraceful it was a tactic that was
used
uh you know at the time
um very similar to the whole build the
wall rhetoric
um to to play to a particular political
slogeneering and carrying out those
types of acts against the Muslim
Community
uh you're not going to face uh much
opposition typically in any meaningful
way that would that would be politically
costly
when he rolled it out at the time there
were people in flight on their way to
the United States
that were held in airports around the
country
children elderly people
that were held in the small rooms and
treated awfully before being put back on
a plane and sent to where they were
there were families that had medical
needs that were never able to
come together he
specifically targeted Muslim countries
to play to that idea of a complete ban
of Muslims which he knew was not
feasible at the time
now personally you know Dallas had the
uh the largest amount the largest number
of uh detainees uh in the airport we
have one of the largest airports in
America and
we took to the airport
and we stayed there for a few days
uh stayed overnight it was one of the
New York Times pictures of the year when
we did our prayer because when we had to
do our prayer it wasn't just Muslims
that came to the airport it was many
people that came to the airport of
different Fates that were outraged by
what they had seen so when we do our
prayer uh there was a protest chant that
you pray we stay
and so the airport had to make room for
us because like a thousand people that
need to have our five daily prayers
so we would do our prayers in the
airport we waited we continued
until the detainees were freed at least
temporarily unfortunately some elements
of that legislation remained and it was
it was an ongoing struggle but look what
I'll say is that those are some of the
more obvious manifestations of
anti-muslim bigotry
but again there's hypocrisy on all sides
of the political aisle here in the
United States
there is islamophobia of different
flavors I think even the term
islamophobia can become contentious
because there are people that attack Us
in different ways and that might not be
as overtly bigoted but
nonetheless are infringing on our rights
to be full American Muslims
and Muslims find themselves in a very
strange political place
where
you've got one side that seemingly wants
to annihilate you
and another side that only accepts you
if you're willing to assimilate
but no one really allows you to be a
full-on American Muslim and so Muslims
find themselves in a very strange place
right now
with all of the political sides with the
political parties what do Muslims sit
politically are they politically engaged
in the function of the United States
where they find themselves political as
a community so
Muslims find themselves in an awkward
place politically that's the best way to
put it we are a religious community
and so we don't find ourselves welcomed
by the left which has a hostility
towards religion and most left spaces
and most liberal spaces in general
because it's uh kind of religion has
many conservative elements right so the
Muslim Community is in its nature
conservative for what that's worth right
it's a conservative Community it's a
community that has certain orthodoxies
and practices that
would make it disagreeable in its nature
and its practice to many on the left and
many on the right just see us as a group
of foreigners
and a threat in that regard so
um we find ourselves in this awkward
place there's also the
presence of sort of the pro-israel uh
dominance of both parties the foreign
policy of both parties is detrimental to
Muslims globally
um the securitization of the Muslim
Community and the name of countering by
and extremism unfortunately the Muslim
Community has had both Republican and
Democratic administrations just run over
its rights
so we find ourselves kind of in this
awkward space right we are a religious
community that's also a minority the
racialization of the Muslim Community
sort of robs us of who we are and how we
get to engage them with uh different
platforms and different peoples around
us so we find ourselves in a very
awkward place is there in general a lack
of representation
in places of power
in politics I think representation is
everything I think that representation
can actually be detrimental sometimes
because you can have people that uh
represent you but that don't actually
represent your your priorities as a
community as a faith community so we
don't want to be tokenized as a
community right we want to be engaged
and engaged fully as Muslims and be
respected as American Muslims you know I
wrote something at the time actually of
Muslim ban I wrote an article for CNN
called I am not your American Muslim I
am not your American Muslim
because we are not a tool of liberals
against conservatives
nor are we simply to be made out to be
your villain or your victim
where a people of faith
where people that have values where
people that want to see our places of
worship Thrive where people that have
something to offer
to this country to the people around us
of good
But ultimately we want to engage
and be engaged with on the basis of who
we actually are not who you need us to
be right now and that's been the problem
uh that we've had so it's not it's not a
lack of representation as much as a lack
of authentic engagement
you mentioned uh
daily prayer
and
if I may looking at the time this might
be time
um and uh if it's okay I would love it
if you allowed me to
follow along at least in uh movement as
you pray sure absolutely
thank you for allowing me to join you in
that uh
can you maybe describe
what
what does the prayer represent what is
the actual practice of prayer like what
is the process like
sure so prayer is the central pillar if
you will of Islam
um
it is the life of the believer
um encapsulated
in to a very specific Act of devotion
that's done at least five times a day so
there are different types of prayer
there's prayer there's supplication so
the the five daily prayers are called
Salah which is the obligatory prayers
and then beyond that there are voluntary
prayers that are done uh throughout the
day as well so you can pray before and
after the obligatory prayers and then
there are other times of the day that
you can pray also and the best prayer
voluntary prayers at night in the middle
of the night because it's the time that
you're closest to God
uh sincere away from the eyes of people
uh Just In the Still of the Night and
you'd pray in a similar way with the
standing and the Bowing and the
prostration reciting the Quran and then
you have supplication and words of
remembrance that you are to do
throughout the day
um between all of that so when people
say do you pray five times a day I say
at least five times a day
um what are the words this application
do they come from the Quran or do they
come from your own heart or do they
where do they come from so basically you
say Allahu Akbar
uh which means I'm going to kill you
right
or so they say right
no God is greater you start off with
that an expression of God's greatness
and then you recite the opening chapter
of the Quran which is uh known as the
first chapter of the Quran in the name
of God the most compassionate the most
merciful all Praises be to God the Lord
of all the worlds most compassionate
most merciful Master of the day of
judgment you alone we worship and from
you alone we seek help guide us to the
straight path the path of those who have
earned your favor not those who have
earned your wrath nor those who have
gone astray so that's a translation of
the first chapter the opening chapter of
the Quran which is known as we recite
that in every one of the units of Prayer
um and then after that we recite
something else from the Quran so some
other portion of the Quran and then we
say Allahu Akbar once again
God is greater we go into bowing and in
bowing we say subhanallah
subhanallah
which means glory be to God the almighty
glory be to God the almighty glory be to
God the almighty and then you come back
up and you say
God has heard the one who has praised
him
and then the response is
and To You O Lord belongs all praise
and then we go into prostration and
prostration is at the heart of the
prayer
and it is the most beautiful portion of
the prayer and it is
the most beloved position
for a servant of God and that which is
most pleasing to God
it's when you say at that point
subhanallah all glory be to God the most
high all glory be to God the most high
so while you put yourself in the lowest
position you acknowledge God being the
most high and the prophet peace and
blessings be upon him said that the
closest that a person is to God is when
they are in prostration that is the time
that your supplications are most
precious and beloved that is the time
that you can cry your heart out that is
the time that you really feel a sense of
great closeness and Devotion to God and
as I was telling you earlier it's a time
that your your mind is under your heart
for a change right the only positioned
physical position that your mind is
actually under your heart and you really
have a chance to pull your emotions out
and to connect deeply to God it's the
prayer of all of the prophets uh Jesus
peace be upon Him is described even
biblically as falling on his face in
prayer and so it really is uh I think
the most intimate moment that you get
with God and the deepest part of the
prayer the word Masjid
which is mosque in Arabic means place of
sujood place of prostration so think of
the rest of prayer as an introduction to
that particular part of the prayer where
you really immerse yourself not that you
shouldn't be immersed in your prayer
throughout but when you're in when
you're in prostration that's where
you're really closest and most connected
to God so we do that
and so some prayers are two units uh
well the first prayer of the day
which is Before Sunrise the earliest
prayer is two units
um the second prayer which is around
noon is four units and then afternoon
another four units and then the sunset
prayer is three units and then the
evening prayer is four units
so each prayer has a different number of
units to it and some voluntary prayers
that surround it when you come back up
you express also a form of greeting
towards God and channeling your prayers
and your blessings towards God you
reiterate the shahada which is the first
pillar of Islam I testify that there is
only one God and that Muhammad is his
servant and messenger and then you read
what's called Salah ibrahimia which is
the abrahamic prayer so you send peace
and blessings upon Muhammad and his
family and Abraham and his family
Abraham peace be upon Him is really at
the core of this religion and so at the
prayer at the end of the prayer you you
send peace and blessings and prayers
upon again both Muhammad and his family
and Abraham and his family
and then you have another chance to make
some of your own personal prayers and
then you say assalamu alaikum
peace Beyond to you in the mercy of God
to your right peace be unto you and the
mercy of God to your left and that means
everything and everyone to your right
everyone and everything to your left so
you imagine a congregation
uh when you're in worship right you're
you're sending that to the angels and
the human beings next to you your fellow
worshipers next to you
and you'll even say you'll seek
forgiveness from God afterwards there's
supplications that surround the prayer
and you will say
that oh Allah oh God you are peace and
from you is peace unto you belongs all
glory and uh all praise almost to say
that you received something in this
prayer that you receive a great sense of
inner peace and now you're spreading
that right so as it really comes into
you then you can give you can give to
the world around you what you generate
in your own heart
and in prayer you generate a great sense
of Tranquility a great sense of peace
the Quran says verily in the remembrance
of God do hearts find contentments
and prayer is an exercise in the
remembrance of God
um that is again obligatory five times a
day
no matter where you are so anywhere in
the world anywhere you find yourself in
your life in in different life
circumstances and you are yeah so
outside coffee shop in the grass outside
as it did a few days ago yeah uh so any
anywhere at all and that means airports
included given the context of our
previous conversation of
um
uh hatred towards uh people of Muslim
faith that means
you probably through the practice of
prayer it attracts people that hate I've
attracted curiosity hate I've had people
walk up to me like hey man you're okay
you know in the herbs everything so most
probably these conversations of
curiosity and the opportunity to
actually uh talk about the values that
you're upset and I try to make it a
point to tell people if I'm about to
pray in front of them so like you know
in the airport let's say for example go
to the corner next to a gate yeah and if
there are people sitting there like hey
I'm about to engage in a prayer I hope
you don't mind they'll really appreciate
the courtesy most of the time
um but no I mean any when those five
times come in and they're kind of
Windows right
um we have to pray and uh
that means at work that means at school
that means when you're when you're
traveling although there are some
concessions that allow you to combine
prayers at certain times when you're
traveling for example
but even then uh you're gonna have to
pray and
um I think that
what that does
to
bring you back to God
no matter what you're doing
it's actually you know you think of it
this way you're in a meeting you're
engaged in something you're really
stressed out and you also have the
ablution before the prayer where you
wash up wash your face wash your limbs
and engage in prayer
what it does for you
and anchoring you in something more
meaningful
when you are in the turmoil of a lot of
times what's not so meaningful
uh is incredible and so it's a gift from
God
and
it is an obligation it's something that
we have to do as Muslims
but if you actually learn its Essence
then
it can feel more like a joy than it is
an obligation
and then you're called to at night
especially again the night prayer is a
big part of who we are as Muslims waking
up in the last part of the night the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
that the the best prayer and the best
fasting was of that of David peace be
upon him so we think of David the
prophet David he's a prophet in Islam as
well I'm sure you'll ask me about about
the whole concept of prophethood you're
hearing Abraham and David and others
right so David peace be upon him he said
that David used to fast every other day
and he used to pray the last third of
the night he'd stand up and pray in the
last third of the night
so fasting uh is a big part of Who We
Are
and praying in the last third of the
night
meaning before that early morning prayer
you know waking up if you can at 4 a.m 4
30 a.m 5 A.M
and praying even for a few minutes
um there's something in the serenity of
the night
that can unlock a new uh a sense of
inner joy and peace that nothing else in
the world can give you
and again that pulls you away from all
the turmoil of day-to-day life
uh if it's little things or if it's big
things you just pulls it pulls you out
of it to remember what is more important
than life so when we think about access
in the last third of the night we're
taught that God says is there anyone
seeking forgiveness that I may forgive
them is there anyone seeking Refuge that
I may Grant it to them is there anyone
asking for anything that I may give it
to them so whatever you're calling upon
him with at that time he's responding to
you
in a way that befits him
and so it's closeness as well
and you would think that you sleep less
so
you're probably more cranky but
um the happiest people in the world are
the people that stand up in that last
start of the night and pray I mean
there's a deeply meditative
contemplative
aspect to it that I that I think
um
probably strengthens your sleep if
anything else once you return to it
there you go see people underestimate
that there's a great sage in Islam he
was asked he said how come the people
who pray at night are the most beautiful
of people and they're they're fresh in
the day it doesn't make sense and he
said because they secluded themselves
with the most merciful and he dressed
them in his light
and so there's a there's a there's a
beauty that it generates
um and that's why we're to Aspire to
that really as as Believers that's kind
of your highest thing like don't just
pray the five prayers if you can pray at
night pray at night and connect at that
time well a good friend of mine Andrew
Huber Mike who's in your scientist from
Stanford he's a big he's upset he's a
amazing podcast called humor and lab but
he's also a scholar of sleep
uh among many other things and so I
would love him to he probably knows the
signs on this too
there's probably good signs that
actually studies uh uh practicing
Muslims to see what
um the the benefits to sleep I would
love to actually
um see what that says we we have amazing
I don't want to cut you off yeah we have
amazing hygiene because of how much we
have to wash up for prayer and it's
great for our limbs as well right
um you know and that's one of the added
benefits right it's good for us worship
that we do is not torturous it's
actually good for us however the core
objective of worship has to remain that
it's something you do out of worship and
something you do out of an a sense of
obligation gratitude to God not because
of those things like I'm not gonna fast
because it's good for my health but I
know it's good for my health to fast but
it's pretty cool when you walk into I'll
share this with you there is a man he
was a a scholar from Turkey an Islamic
scholar from turkey and he had visited
Us in Dallas and he was 108 years old
and he could still pray bowing and
prostrating
I mean his Limbs and you think about
that like someone at that age still
being able to do that so I'm sure it's
good for your limbs it's good for your
health good for your gut good for your
sleep good for your mind I think the
mind one is is there really one we've
been talking about and that's really
really the really the big one and in the
in the small day-to-day psychological
sense in the big philosophical sense of
what it means to be a human being I we
should also mention that
and during the prayer as you've
explained you should face Mecca
so what is Mecca and
was the experience of visiting Mecca
like
so Mecca is the home that Abraham peace
be upon Him built along with his son
Ishmael peace be upon him
and it gives the Muslims a unified
direction of prayer it's sort of at the
center geographically
of who we are and
when we pray towards it
is not that
it's not that that's the only place that
you can supplicate turn towards but it
gives us a unified sense of direction it
gives us a unified sense of Prayer
so Mecca is
our Qibla it's our place of Direction
when we are alive and when we are dead
so actually we pray facing towards it
when we die we are also faced towards it
in our Graves
and it kind of gives us that unifying
spirit so this is uh the valley of Becca
also in the Bible spoken about the
valley of Becca
and where other biblical Scholars would
also mention Mount Perrin
and it is the place that Adam uh in the
Quran Adam peace be upon him first had a
place constructed there as a place of
worship
from the Angels towards God and then
when Abraham settles Hagar and Ishmael
and Mecca
they build this house of worship
and that is where the gushing Springs of
zamzam are mentioned where God sends an
angel
to
give a miracle to Hagar and Ishmael that
they can sustain themselves from as
they're not left in the desert so
Ishmael being the firstborn son of
Abraham
is given a place and there's a story and
a history that's going to unfold from
that place of Mecca and then Isaac is
born peace be upon Him 13 years later
and there's a story and a history that
comes from that but ultimately Mecca is
the center Mecca is where we turn
towards for prayer Marquez where we
perform the pilgrimage the Hajj
pilgrimage
once in our lives at least if we can
physically and financially if we find
ourselves capable we at least perform
the Hajj pilgrimage once in our
lifetimes but there are other
pilgrimages throughout the year you can
go
at any time of the day any time of the
year you will find people that will be
performing The Pilgrimage
an iteration of the pilgrimage in Mecca
and it's an incredible practice it
really is a place where
you feel like you're no longer in this
world I mean it's it's it's incredible
so we all go there donning what's known
as the Aram Garb so the men will wear
uh just these white uh garments which
are
resembling or they they resemble the
garments that we will be buried in
and whether you're a king or a prince or
a peasant and you know in classical
terms whoever you are whatever
distinction you have you're all the same
and the women will wear a simple garment
as well so you go there you relinquish
all of the pretensions and concerns and
superficial barriers and distinctions
that exist in this life and we do what's
called tawaf circle around uh the Kappa
symbolically putting God at the center
of our lives
we do seven rounds between Safa and
marijuana the two mountains where Hagar
when she once ran between those two
mountains with her baby Ishmael looking
for water trusting God was provided for
we too
go between the two mountains of Safa and
marwa to express that trust in God and
to follow in that way and these are
ultimately these are the rituals that
Abraham himself engaged in
um
in our tradition and the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him engaged in
and so we engaged in the exact same
rituals and there are Divine wisdoms to
them that we may not even be able to
unpack and reflect upon
but it really is in that place where
um you find
the most beautiful Global expression of
Islam you see people from all over the
world people that don't speak the same
languages people from all sorts of
backgrounds and they're all doing the
exact same thing and in a matter of
seconds when the call of prayer comes
in a matter of seconds
two three million people get arranged in
perfect rows for prayer right and it
just it looks like this perfect Optical
you know uh vision of just Beauty when
you see people in unison standing bowing
prostrating
and you don't know who the person next
to you is
and that's where you know you you know
Malcolm X you read about the history of
Malcolm X when he wins a Hajj that's
where his entire world view shifts
uh not just his previous
uh baggage but
the dream that he then had the
possibilities that he saw for people to
be able to overcome some of the false
distinctions that we have
uh race and class
and to see
God as one and to come together
and worship him alone and also seeing
each other equal participants in that
worship if you could just Linger on it a
little bit
I think you've mentioned that Malcolm X
has been in part misunderstood
um what are some aspects of him that are
misunderstood well I think reading his
autobiography is
extremely important for anyone that
wants to understand him right so you
read him his own words
Malcolm lived the tragedy of being
a young disenfranchised black man in
America who went through all of the
difficulties that were posed
in a 1950s America
uh towards him I mean he went through
the system and it was
awful for him and he had to pull himself
out of that and make himself into
an incredible orator an incredible uh
leader
uh that suddenly had a pretty empowering
vision and a calm and and nonetheless
courageous but a calm presence to him
uh and was able to bring together people
especially uplift black people in
America to believe in themselves
uh young young men in America in America
and in prisons in particular will read
the autobiography of Malcolm X and see
hope for themselves to come out of the
darkness
of
you know being imprisoned not just by
the bars in front of them
but also by what they thought to be
their own worth prior to that moment and
so Malcolm climbs out of uh that and he
goes through multiple phases so
Malcolm dies as an orthodox Muslim
who does not believe in the superiority
of One race over the other
finds great Tranquility in the practice
of the Hajj
um great clarity and I think you read
his letters from Mecca
and he talks about his his change his
transformation in particular and it was
a process uh it's it's a process for him
but he inspires the likes of Muhammad
Ali to become the person that he becomes
and inspires many other people
uh till today
to really
see themselves and see the world
differently in light of that
understanding of monotheism
so he was deeply a man of faith and
throughout his life the nature of that
faith has changed as he grew as he
interacted with
I would say a cruel society that he was
living right right
uh you mentioned he inspired uh Muhammad
Ali who I don't think it's an
overstatement to say is probably the
most quite possibly the most famous
American Muslim from America because you
maybe make a few comments as an athlete
yourself uh
what impact uh did uh Islam have on
Muhammad Ali's life and what and vice
versa what impact did he have as a
leader as a religious figure uh on the
Muslim Community
I think Muhammad Ali his quotes on on
Islam are precious because he talks
about how he sought the wealth of this
world and he found it in Islam he found
a greater meaning and he attributes
everything that he became uh to his
faith
uh his sense of strength and commitment
the willingness to take a stand uh
for the truth
when it was extremely unpopular
on the basis of his faith and on the
basis of his integrity
I think that he inspired people with his
confidence
and
his coherence I mean he was incredibly
eloquent
I mean poetic
and just unwavering
seemed unbreakable so as Relentless as
he was in the ring he was even more so
outside of the Ring the man could not be
broken
and everything was stacked up against
them but he perseveres and he does so
then through Parkinson's
and chooses to live a life of
of giving a life of service a life of
using his platform
to bring up issues of importance and to
Champion the rights of others so he
wasn't satisfied at any point in his
life would simply being a boxing great a
boxing champion
he uses it for so much more
and so he goes down as one of the most
famous Americans period of the 20th
century one of the most transformative
Americans period of the 20th century not
just American Muslims
uh and a lot of people that loved him
when he died
would not have loved him
if they were around in the 1960s and
1970s
you know they said they loved him when
he couldn't speak anymore you know many
of those who celebrated him at the time
his death
would have been his greatest opponents
at the peak of his career and when he
was taking the stands that he was taking
yeah he was fearless and part of this
his faith was helping him take the
Fearless stance but throughout all of it
given the strength I think he's also a
symbol of compassion through all the way
through all the fun kind of
yeah the poetic nature of who who he was
in The Fearless nature who he was
there's always like a like a deep love
for for the sport
and for Humanity absolutely and that's
the thing right that was so obvious that
despite everything that had happened to
him
he never loses himself neither to the
fame nor to the fear yeah he he always
stays himself he's authentic
um and you know when I went to his
funeral and it was one of the most
beautiful
things I'd ever seen because
everyone
in Louisville Kentucky had a story with
Muhammad Ali right the guy that he saves
from committing suicide the school kids
the the hotel shuttle driver the gas
station worker everyone has a story of
Muhammad Ali in Louisville Kentucky
and when he
when he when he passes away
everybody comes out and stands in front
of their homes and they take the casket
and they drive around the streets of
Louisville and he had this dream I'm
very close to some of his uh some of his
children
incredible people by the way uh just
incredible human beings
and he had this dream that he shared
with them that
um he was jogging around the streets of
Louisville Kentucky
and everyone had come out to wave to him
and so he's running around jogging and
and waving to everybody in the streets
of Louisville Kentucky then he gets to
the cemetery and he says he flies into
the heavens
so his his dream and he had this dream
years ago I mean if you look at his
funeral
it's such a beautiful
you can't make it up it's such a
beautiful
moment where it seems to come to reality
because everybody in Louisville just
comes out and just Waves by says casket
and then when he gets to the cemetery
the gates close and
he goes off to be with his Lord and we
pray that it's a good place for him
so Muhammad Ali is probably one of the
great 20th century representatives of
Islam
um for me personally at least
my bias one of the great modern
Representatives is uh khabib
nurmagomedov who's a great fighter and a
great human being so you've gotten a
chance to meet him I should also say
your friends your good friends with a
lot of really interesting Muslim people
I mean it's just it's such a widespread
religion there's just so much variety of
different people that are practicing
Muslims so
um what uh does khabib represent what do
you like about him as a Muslim what do
you like about him as a person as
representative of the religion I think I
think Habib
first of all he is a great person you
know humble person he's shown and now
Islam as well kind of following in that
they're really showing the beauty of
faith in their lives their culture their
values
um everything from the way that he
carried himself in a principled way
uh you know like like every Muslim kid
grew up in a public school cafeteria
before Islamic schools were a thing in
the United States not eating pork for
example and kind of being the odd person
out so when he got a fighter and uh
in in the UFC scene and doesn't drink
alcohol kind of maintains like a very
um
consistent principles
uh you know attachment to his religion
it really is inspiring growing up we had
Hakeem Olajuwon in the 1990s basketball
who's fasting in the NBA I think Habib
was is that for a lot of people a lot of
young people today and and people in
general and I think beyond that uh the
values
how he honored his father
and how he honors his mother
and how he continues to put Family First
that's a beautiful part of Islam that's
a beautiful part of our value system
we have a lot of emphasis on family
family is Central to Islam and his
honoring of his father was so beautiful
and again what he's willing to do for
his mother
you know it's just so beautiful and I
think that we saw it frankly even with
Morocco in the World Cup
you know there was a lot of islamophobia
in this recent World Cup episode you
know a lot of the criticism of Qatar
while no government is beyond reproach
uh certainly no government is beyond
reproach but had very obvious blatance
islamophobic undertones and then with
Morocco Rising being the first African
Muslim uh Arab team you know to get that
far in the World Cup what did you see
beyond the consistent honoring of
Palestine you also saw the honoring of
the mothers every single time the game
would end they go into a prostration of
gratitude so just like we prostrate in
prayer a prostration of gratitude and
then they go and they kiss their
mother's foreheads dance with their
mothers on the field hug their moms and
honor their moms that's Islam for you
khabib after his fight what does he do
he prostrates
points up to the heavens it's God and
then he prostrates
the whole Moroccan team beautifully
prostrates uh even when they lost they
prostrated out of gratitude they honored
their mothers
so I think sometimes athletes are able
to demonstrate some of these beautiful
values of Islam in a way that the world
can maybe see them in a different light
the values of humility and the values of
love
love broadly but love for family and and
look how everyone around Habib talks
about him right no one ever no one ever
says he's a jerk no one ever says he's
mistreated them they've all got stories
right and that's what a beautiful Muslim
does a beautiful human being you treat
the people in such a way that all these
stories come out later of how good you
were to everyone that came into contact
with you and Habib was that person uh he
is that person he does a great job of
treating people with a lot of respect
obviously no one is perfect right I mean
imperfections are for everybody but
I definitely think that um he did a
beautiful job representing
his faith in those moments
um you know beyond punching people in
the face that's kind of a different
subject
smashing faces not the Smashing faces
part the prostration part and the
humility
I tell you man he's not humble in the
ring right he's uh he he would Maul his
opponents right but I mean as a
practitioner as a fan of the sport of
all grappling sports for me there's also
a beauty to the art of uh grappling and
and the fighting sports but yes
um I think his again humility his honor
uh outside the cage is uh is exemplary
and the money the fame the power hasn't
changed the man no not at all and that's
that's actually I think the most
beautiful part when I met him
um I found him to be as humble as he is
on screen and that's always very
endearing and all the stories of the
people that have been around him for a
much longer time very humble man I pray
for him honestly I pray for Islam I pray
for that family
um that God keeps them grounded and
protected and together
and that they maintain that beautiful
spirit because even if you if you just
watch the lead up of to the last uh
the last fight with Islam just the way
they carry themselves their day to day
you know they never relinquish their
prayers
they never relinquish their family uh
ties the things that make them who they
are to be better Fighters because they
don't see
that
they have to let go of those things in
fact they attribute all of their worldly
success uh to that that faith and so you
know beautiful examples and I think that
it's good for young Muslims to see
themselves in that and it's good for
other people to see Islam uh through
that as well When you mention the
prophets you often say peace and
blessings be upon them yes
um what is that phrase mean is why do
you say it is it to celebrate the people
is it is a constant reminder that these
are figures that should be celebrated
absolutely so it's part of our tradition
that when we say the name of a prophet
at least the first time in the
conversation we say peace be upon him
and then afterwards it's still
praiseworthy to say peace be upon him so
if you're reading an Islamic article and
you see in parentheses pbuh
peace Beyond to him or peace be upon him
when I was in high school I often tell
the story I wrote an article about Jesus
peace be upon him in Islam and
Christianity
and my teacher comes up to me and she
says you can't do that and I said what
she like slams the paper on on the desk
she says you can't say Jesus
and I said no no pbuh peace be upon him
so that's what it means and something
that we reserve for the prophets of God
and we honor them with
so who is Muhammad
so the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him is the descendant of Abraham peace
be upon him through Ishmael
God promises
Hagar and Ishmael that he will make of
him a great nation
and so there are prophets that are
descended from Isaac
and then from the brothers of Isaac
Comes The Prophet Muhammad
and he is the final prophet of a long
line of prophets and we do not
distinguish between the prophets in
regards to
their role and so Islam has a very
accessible theology it's something that
resonates with
a professor at an ivy league university
and you know a person who maybe even
illiterate this idea of one God that
sent many prophets and all of the
prophets had a singular message worship
one God and respond to the messages of
that one God through his Messengers
So Adam
through Muhammad you have many of the
prophets that are mentioned in the Old
Testament
Moses peace be upon him being the most
spoken about prophet in the Quran in
fact Abraham
um Jesus peace be upon Him many of these
prophets that are familiar uh to people
all of them are considered prophets and
Islam the prophet Muhammad uh peace be
upon him being the last of them
he comes at a time where there was still
a lot of confusion
about what the world had just
encountered in Christ in Jesus Christ
peace be upon him so you got to think
about it this way that this is still uh
you know he's born in the sixth century
there is still great debate about who
Jesus was the Council of nicaea happens
in the 4th Century where you kind of
have a standardizing of Western
Christianity but then you have Eastern
Christians that are still maintaining
very different theologies and very
different conceptions of Christ
there is no Arabic Bible at the time and
he kind of brings together
the message and the mission of all of
those prophets and it fits perfectly
into a singular string of thought
where you don't have to reject Jesus
peace be upon him but Islam also is
staunchly opposed to the idea of a
trinity the idea of a begotten son of
God
that all the conceptions of the Messiah
and there were many claimants of the
Messiah prior to Christ peace be upon
him
uh none of them included an idea of
Trinity or of him actually being a part
of God himself a begotten Son of God but
rather a Great and Mighty Prophet
that would restore glory on Earth so he
he really captures theologically or
rather we would say God captures through
him theologically
a coherence and a unifying message of
all of the prophets
that there's only one God and that that
God has sent
messages and scriptures
to ultimately guide people back towards
him and that all of the prophets are
equal and the sight of God there is no
distinction between them
and that's we are to live our lives in
accordance with the message as best
manifested by the messenger and so the
prophets are exemplary human beings and
this is where we kind of sometimes maybe
have
um a difference you know someone will
say well
you know Noah did this and David did
this as Muslims we don't believe we
don't hold many of the stories that have
been attributed to these prophets uh to
be true
um we don't believe that the prophets
are capable of major sins we believe
they're exemplary human beings
and that they kind of give us
a manifestation of the scriptures that
they were sent with of how to live Noble
lives and the most documented human
being in history is the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him we know everything
about him his family life
his day-to-day the way he would greet
you the way he'd look at you everything
about his physical appearance
it's documented in immaculate detail and
Muslims have a standard that they then
seek to live up to
with how to treat your family how to be
in your community how to be in your
worship how to be in your social
interactions how to carry yourself with
your neighbors it's a full complete
guide book through his example
where we have the Quran which is the
word of God and then you have the
biography of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him which is
a living manifestation of that word that
has been documented for us to live by
until the end of time
so Muhammad
if I may peace be upon him uh
is is really the yeah like you said the
manifestation the thing to be the
example of a good man yes example of a
good human being
is the Quran the word of God
so the Quran and this is what
distinguishes the Quran in many ways uh
from other scriptures so as Muslims we
do believe
that God has sent divine revelation
prior we believe that the Original
Scriptures
prior to the multiple versions and
the changes and revisions throughout
history The Original Scriptures that
were given to the prophets whether it
was the Torah
to Moses or the Gospels
were all original Divine Revelations but
they've been changed over time the Quran
is the word of God with a promise that
he will guard it for all of time and
it's probably one of the greatest
Miracles because in 1400 years
we have the Quran preserved through oral
transmission and through written
transmission
and there are almost 2 billion Muslims
in the world and they all recite this
book the exact same way and there's only
one version of it and so when I'm
reciting the Quran if I say U or e or ah
differently
an Ethiopian Muslim a Chinese Muslim a
yemeni Muslim can correct me an
eight-year-old kid in any one of those
countries can correct me because they
will know that this is not how it's
memorized and so it was memorized from
the start committed to memory in the
time of the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and preserved in writing and
passed down and memorized by millions
and millions of people around the world
and it's 600 pages
and you can't go to a city in America
a city in the United States of America
and not find at least one person or a
group of people that memorize it that
have committed it to memory and so
there's an emphasis on committing it to
memory as well as understanding it and
applying it and practicing it as much as
we can
what are some
maybe
deep or insightful differences between
the Quran the Torah and the Bible
well like I said so so you've got the
original Revelations of those scriptures
but there are so many versions of those
scriptures and there are times
throughout history where there have been
changes just from an objective
perspective right uh
what is the original scripture that was
given to uh Moses peace be upon him and
what was initially communicated to Jesus
peace be upon him those things
um have changed over time
however there's still some truth that
remains even in those scriptures and so
there are still things that line up
especially with the Old Testament and
Islam there are still many things that
line up between the two
the Bible as well the New Testament now
Matthew Mark Luke and John it's it's
different because these are not uh
Original Scriptures these are
testimonies that were obviously
collected
around the entire phenomenon of the
coming of Christ but the authors
themselves the biographies
the documentation even of those original
testimonies and gospels what made the
cut in terms of being included within
the gospels and what didn't because
there are many gospels at the time in
that sense is different from what we
believe was scripture communicated to
Jesus peace be upon him
uh the Quran is different in several
ways but it confirms uh what came before
it but it's the document and preserved
word of God to be recited throughout
throughout time so it confirms much of
what came before it uh and it resides
amongst us and within us uh for for the
rest of time and through it
we honor uh those Revelations that came
through the prophets of old
because the essence the core of what
came through those Revelations is
preserved in the Quran and with us I
tell people this all the time that you
know the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him introduced
uh Jesus peace be upon him
and uh even Moses peace be upon him to
much of the world
there are Muslims around the world that
are named ASA that are named Jesus there
are Muslims around the world that are
named Ibrahim Abraham Muslims around the
world named Musa and they learned of
these figures through the Revelation
that came to the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon Him Noah
Maryam one of the most popular names in
Islam Mary peace be upon her whole
chapter in the Quran named after
Mariam which is actually what I was
reciting in the prayer was the chapter
of Maryam the chapter of the story of
Mary peace be upon her so the Quran
contains the stories it contains
um
legislation and law but primarily it was
revealed over 23 years so it actually
was coming in accordance with some of
the events that were unfolding in the
life of the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him
the first 13 years of that was primarily
belief in God uh belief in the Hereafter
and things that surrounded the court
Creed of Islam and then legislation law
stories of the prophets uh came down in
accordance with the unfolding events as
well as prophesizing some of the things
that were to come
and speaking about some of the things
that just happened and it is completed
in the lifetime of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon and memorized and then
communicated to generation after
generation after generation so that we
have it in its pristine Fashions now
billions of people yeah just all across
the world all the different cultures all
memorizing the same words
one of the pillars or maybe I should say
one of the central practices is the
month of Ramadan uh what is the
importance of this month
um what is the process of it entail also
so Islam has I think it'd be good to
maybe lay this out for people the the
articles of faith in the pillars of
Islam so the articles of Faith are six
articles of faith and this kind of lays
the foundation for the Creed of Islam so
belief in God belief in the Angels
belief in the messages belief in The
Messengers okay belief in the day of
judgment and belief in Divine decree so
these are the six articles of faith
belief in God belief in the Angels
belief in the messages being the
scriptures belief in The Messengers
being the prophets belief in the day of
judgment and belief in Divine decree
that's what you have to believe to be a
Muslim you have to believe in those six
things right and then you go to
the pillars of faith the five pillars of
faith
are sort of or they make up the
structure of those articles of Faith the
practice of the Muslim so
to be a Muslim you testify
that there's only one God worthy of
worship and unconditional obedience and
then you testify that Muhammad is the
final messenger of God
that's the first pillar it's the actual
testimony entering into Islam then it's
the five daily prayers
practicing the five daily prayers at
least as a bare minimum obligation the
mandatory charity which is called the
zakat that Muslims have to give at least
2.5 percent of their retained earnings
uh to specific categories of Charity
then it is the fasting of the month of
Ramadan
the mandatory fasting of the month of
Ramadan and then it's the Hajj if you
can do so the pilgrimage if you can do
so once in your lifetime so those are
the five pillars of Islam so Ramadan
is a month in which Muslims engage in
this incredible spiritual boot camp
now fasting can mean different things to
different people uh when we fast we fast
from before sunrise to sunset for an
entire month and there's no food or
water period
and no intimacy as well so you would
abstain from intimacy with your spouse
as well in that time no food or water no
bread no nothing you don't eat or drink
even if you live in Texas where you get
the where you get these long hot days in
the summer and of course Islam is on a
lunar calendar so it moves every every
year about 10 days earlier
during that time you restrict the intake
to the body so that you can focus on the
intake of the Soul
so instead of being focused on
consumption constant consumption you are
consuming words of remembrance words of
prayer you're to be hyper conscious of
not doing anything that would
spiritually validate your fast just as
you would physically so just like you
won't eat or drink you certainly won't
engage in sin though you shouldn't
engage in sins throughout the year but
uh you know you're not going to speak
words of evil you're not going to gossip
or slander you try to fast with your
eyes not look at things that are not
praiseworthy so you try to engage in a
wholesome Act of disciplining yourself
with a conscious of consciousness of God
but then channel that into engaging the
soul instead exercising the soul instead
and what you'll find with Muslims and
this act of God Consciousness where they
reduce the consumption as they become
far more grateful for the blessings of
God because throughout our lives we just
take sips of water we eat what we can we
snack
when you're abstaining from that you
become so much more grateful for that
sip of water so much more grateful for
that bite of food so much more aware of
the one who provided those blessings to
you so much more aware of those that
don't have the same access to those
blessings that you have so you also
develop a sense of empathy for the poor
that don't have access to those
blessings on a regular basis that can't
help but fast
and on top of that again spiritually you
are engaged in extra reading at that
time people are listening to more
lectures people are uh engaged in extra
acts of devotion extracts of Charity
Muslims are most charitable in the month
of Ramadan so you just feel great and
it's hard to explain to someone that
doesn't do it because it sounds like
torture to people right what in the
world are you doing
you know at four o'clock on a hot Texas
day not eating or drinking you're
probably dehydrated and cranky have a
caffeine headache and you probably can't
wait for this month to be over but in
reality you talk to Muslims their
favorite time of the year is Ramadan you
feel amazing you feel absolutely
incredible because you taste a different
type of consumption you feed your soul
for a change and in that process
you connect with God in a way
that you simply could not without the
distractions of the day-to-day
throughout the year
now it's good that it's one one month of
the year because it's it's honestly
physically taxing right so
it gives you a chance to experience it
for that one month but then you're
encouraged to fast a few days of the
year as well outside of the month of
Ramadan to keep that connection
what are the hardest parts that maybe
for people outside of uh uh the Muslim
faith
um
yeah we'll be curious about
well I think the hardest part is is
physically is it physical or is it the
spiritual I mean uh so as Ramadan goes
on
um your acts of worship increase so in
the last 10 nights of Ramadan
um there is an intense
period
of prayer throughout the night so every
night in Ramadan we have something
called the Tuttle we prayers the title
we prayers are about an hour hour and a
half of prayer outside of the five daily
prayers so the mosques are packed every
night and Ramadan
um the last 10 nights of Ramadan people
will engage in prayer throughout the
entire night so the only sleep that
you're probably getting
is actually a couple of hours in the
morning before you go to work
so it's everything sort of put together
the disruption of schedule the
disruption of diet the physically
exerting yourself
but
the way you feel
is unmatched I mean you feel
so fulfilled
through that deprivation and it's
actually the point you know it all ties
back together when you talk about even
tests and trials that God does not
deprive us of anything except that he
gives us something greater in return
and you do not deprive yourself of
anything for the sake of God except that
he gives you something greater in return
and so fasting is an exercise in
patience that unlocks an infinite sense
of gratitude and a greater connection to
God
so many people predict that Islam will
surpass Christianity as the largest
religion by the end of the century
uh by the number of its adherents and
practitioners what responsibility does
that play some people like you who is a
religious leader who is somebody who
teaches who grows who cares for the
community for the Muslim Community but
actually for all people
well I think what that means is that we
have a responsibility to
teach and live our faith in the most
beautiful of ways not
its values and ideals are not just
expressed by you but experienced by
everyone around you
and so what I often teach my community
is that look of Muslims in the area what
are they
what are your neighbors experiencing of
you what are people experiencing of you
you know and there's there's statistics
to Muslims being uh most charitable
communities in America uh we're a
community of great service a community
of volunteering a community that greatly
enriches the world around us
I think that oftentimes people forget
the history of Muslims you know being at
the Forefront of contributing in the
areas of medicine and Science and all
sorts of ways education really changing
the world through their commitment to
Faith
but on a deeply personal level
you know
it's important for us
to be Representatives
of the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him in a way that makes islamophobia
impossible
I you know I I tell people this that
it's very hard you know you mentioned
the United States of hate uh the
documentary and uh the one man the
protester who met me and sort of changed
his world view
it's very hard for
people to believe what they hear about
Islam if they see you live it
now that does not excuse bigotry that
doesn't excuse the prejudice against
Muslims but it's important for us
to sort of take it as a responsibility
as Muslims
to channel our faith in the most
beautiful of ways
God describes faith in the Quran in the
chapter of Abraham peace be upon him as
a tree with firm foundations
the Firm Foundation being the testimony
of Faith the Oneness of God so the tree
of monotheism with firm foundations and
then branches high in the sky providing
shade to everything and everyone around
you
and producing fruit at all times the
tree of faith of a Muslim is not
seasonal so you should be producing with
your faith at all times good works and
things that people can can actually
experience and I think that Muslims have
historically contributed to the world
around them
and I think that Muslims today are still
contributing to the world around them
but I think that we can never do enough
of holding ourselves accountable to the
message that we hold dear to our hearts
and trying to be the best
representatives of that message and of
that Messenger to the world around us
so not only are you a a religious leader
in the Muslim Community but you have a
lot of friends
uh who are from different religions uh
you have a lot of Jewish friends
as we've talked about a lot offline
um and we'll probably hopefully get a
chance to talk to as well here but on
that topic let me bring up um another
tragic event that was just a little bit
less than a year ago in the In This Very
Community here in Dallas there was a
synagogue hostage crisis
um can you describe what happened and
what was your experience like through it
and afterwards and
um what were the bad things you saw and
what are the good things you saw in the
community
the Colleyville
synagogue situation it's kind of surreal
that we're coming up on a year of that
but I'll actually tell you exactly what
happened that morning
um I was out with the family
and that morning I kid you not that very
morning I was telling my kids the story
of Muhammad Ali talking that man out of
committing suicide off the roof and I
showed them the YouTube video my wife
pulled it up on her phone kids were
sitting in the back seat we talked about
that that video
and talked about that importance of
helping people
we also went to visit a loved one in the
cemetery that day and we went to
breakfast so we're out as a family that
day right and there's a lot of meaning
that's sort of coming together
for us and a lot of discussion deep
discussion we're having as a family
and then some of our community groups we
get this message that there is a
synagogue that's been taken uh hostage
a rabbi and his congregation taken as
hostages and
go to this Facebook link and it was the
feed of the synagogue and you could hear
the gunman shouting
and it became apparent
um very early on that it was a man that
was claiming to be Muslim that was
holding them hostage
now all these synagogue massacres all
these places of worship were not
attacked by Muslims right this is
a different type of situation but
my first instinct was
like all that happened this morning was
not random
so I told my wife and I told my kids I'm
gonna go down there
uh it's a Colleyville
um she was very supportive obviously
there was a moment of shock
and like kids were like wait what and I
said look remember what we talked about
this morning
um we can't be indifferent to the stuff
we we still go back and revisit that day
you know like it's crazy how it was all
falling into place it's not an accident
right
so I dropped them off at home and I
started to drive to Colleyville
I called the um Irving Police Department
and I asked them to call the Colleyville
Police Department
so that they could kind of know that I'm
coming down there
I called
some of the faith leaders in the
community to see if they could put me in
touch with those on the ground
so that I wouldn't get shot when I
showed up there
and eventually I had to wait out outside
until I got clearance to come through
and to just offer whatever support I
could pastoral support
um support with trying to free the
hostages of the synagogue at the time it
was operating out of a church right
across the street from the synagogue
um
a day long just wondering you know what
was going to happen
looking at the family of the rabbi at
the time wondering what was going to
happen
I'm trying to just be as supportive as I
possibly could at that time
thankfully uh they all got out in the
evening
and I think that
you know
looking back on that day
like my wife actually asked me I said
would you have done it differently and I
said no I really wouldn't because I
think that that
things happen sometimes you've got to
act on your good instincts sometimes
right when you talk about like being
calculated
I think sometimes
were calculated when we shouldn't be and
that's when that good Instinct comes in
where you're called to do something else
so what did it feel like to be a Muslim
in a situation like that
I mean did you was there were you a
human being were you a religious
yeah I don't practitioner I don't I
don't see I can't I can't separate
anything about myself in that situation
right so
when I had to pray I had to pray
to help people out to give people words
of comfort
to try to appeal to the senses of
whoever I could at the time
I didn't see myself as like uh a guy
trying to
trying to show a particular part of
Islam in there I just saw myself as
someone that was trying to help a family
get their their husband and father back
right and so it was more of just like
that part of me was was there
you know you can you can kind of see
yourself right this is the irony of it
when Christ Church New Zealand happened
uh that was kind of our worst nightmare
as Texas Muslims because we've had armed
groups in front of our mosques
threatening to do what that man did in
Christchurch
and so when you see a wife and kids
um wondering if they're going to get
their their dad back
you kind of see yourself there and so I
just saw myself in that situation what
would I want people to be doing for me
in that moment what would I want people
to be telling my family in that moment
so that's really where I went to and
that's really where where I dug into and
I prayed a lot that day a lot a lot for
the right words for the right actions
what I could do to just help
what are the lessons now a year later
that you take away from that day and the
day so many lessons just
don't be indifferent
don't be indifferent to the suffering
around you even that's distant from you
because it's somehow related to you so
just don't be indifferent
So you you're proud that you stepped up
and you went there and then yeah look I
don't I don't think um
I don't think I did much I'm being
really honest this is not me trying to
be humble here I don't think I did much
I think I did what I was what I was
called to do
um
I wish that it never happens right as a
whole but
I'm glad that the relationships that
have been built over time uh came into
being in that day right we could call
upon people that we knew call upon each
other and as a community where they come
together you know Dallas has been
through a lot a lot of pain
but we've come together through a lot of
pain as well so it's it's kind of one of
those things where we're United in our
pain you know when you suffer together
uh you build you build certain bonds
together so Dallas has been through a
lot as a community
um but we've we've come together through
a lot as a community
yeah the thing about violence and War it
destroys it caused so much suffering but
it also sort of brings out some of the
best aspects of human nature and unites
people it's uh it's an interesting way
how our human civilization functions
well that's the beauty that you don't
just want to see but you also want to be
you know we're living in a climate where
there's a lot of that right so how do
you how do you actually uh
get through that and actually
not allow yourself to succumb to that
and be another voice in that
polarization
it seems that throughout history and
still in the world today
religion has been a source of some of
the of a lot of polarization a lot of
conflict even War
um why do you think that is
listen I think at the essence of it
as always some sort of political
instability
that leaves behind a brutalized
population
and vulnerabilities that can be
exploited
as I said in the 20th century
with the bloodiest Century that we've
had to date
where does religion fall in any of that
where does religion fall in the isms
where does religion fall in the world
wars
where does religion fall and and much of
that even when we talk about things like
the Crusades remove the Islamic framing
the Crusades the Crusades were they
really about religion uh the Mongols and
the destruction of the Mongols was it
about religion
Myanmar and the rohingya today is it
about Buddhism so I think that these are
essentially political issues political
causes where you have people that rise
up and that use religion to disguise
things that are far far far from
religion and if you want to manipulate a
religious scripture you could turn any
book
any Scripture into a violent scripture
if you have a violent Aim so I think
that that's where you find people
manipulating versus manipulating
religion
uh to justify sick ideologies
that are based
and thrive in political instability so
these are fundamentally political
geopolitical conflicts not religious
conflicts absolutely look when you talk
about a group like Isis
Islam has been in Iraq for a very very
long time
Iraq has been bombed by now five
consecutive presidents or four it's been
bombed into the stone ages there is no
political infrastructure it's
Devastation and destruction and
Desperation as a result of that
many of the old Saddam Loyalists and
saddam's regime was was a secularist
regime are now heads of Isis right it
just moved into that when you create
that type of Chaos
you generate an environment where groups
like Isis are bound to rise out of
and so
Islam did not you know cause this people
didn't wake up in Iraq one day and say
hey let's create a group called Isis
because Islam tells us to
all right
Iraq was bombed into this place
and we have to not just free religion
from the responsibility from having to
Bear the responsibility
of much of the hatred and violence but
we have to interrogate
the political instability that was
caused
were we Justified
As Americans these are a taxpayer
dollars
were we Justified
with what was done in Iraq do we even
know what was done in Iraq and
Afghanistan
these drones that drop using our tax
dollars under Democratic and Republican
regimes
and kill
thousands of innocent people in weddings
in Yemen and Somalia
are these Justified when you think about
dehumanization
can the average American name a single
victim of the Iraq War
is there a picture that comes to your
mind is there a person absolutely not
because that's the dehumanization
now I often talk about Dr Martin Luther
King Jr his progression
as a faith leader in America as a
political leader in America Dr King was
deeply unpopular when he took a stand on
Vietnam and he mentions how first he had
to see
Vietnam
through the lens of the soldiers because
many of the soldiers that were lost
American soldiers right and that was
that was a crime that they were sent to
fight a war that they should not have
been sent to fight and there was an
injustice that was done towards them he
said but things really changed when he
started to see it from the other side of
the bullet when he started to see the
world through Vietnam through the
Vietnamese child
and that's where he resorted to Breaking
the silence that's where he changed his
tune because we dehumanize our victims
so much that they're not even relevant
to our discourse until they become able
villains
to our story
and then now they're attacking us
because they hate us now they're blowing
us up because they hate us their
religion tells them to do this to us
what have we allowed to be done to them
using our tax dollars
in our name
right so I think that we have to
interrogate the political chaos that was
caused not just not just free religion
from the groups that were created but
what was done to those countries and
what continues to be done in many of
these places yeah when um
the The Pride that people had about
America where everybody came together
after 9 11 and there was all the
American flags
that was beautiful to see but then you
have to transfer that and I wish all of
us Americans could go and see the
daughters that would lose their parents
the parents that would lose their
daughters and sons because the bombs
dropped
um the the thousands the tens of
thousands of civilians that died
um in Afghanistan and in Iraq because of
the decisions made
in the name of politics like if we just
met those families and if you if we if
we empathize with them and just put
ourselves in their place
uh it's impossible not to feel hate
for America for everybody I mean I I
visited Ukraine and spoke to a lot of
ukrainians and they said um
you know there's there's loved ones that
are Russians before the war but now all
they have is hate
and uh if you ask many of them will they
ever forgive not not not the regime
not the soldiers will they ever forgive
Russians they many of them say never
and that never feels like it's a
generational never
um I mean look
you think about this you know if your
grandparents were wiped out in a drone
attack your parents
your brothers your sisters all of your
loved ones and you're missing a leg and
an eye
and the world does not take you into
consideration you'll never be seen or
considered in the halls of Congress or
discussed
what are you gonna grow up with right
but the thing is is that we should not
be speaking about this only from the
standpoint of oh shoot they're going to
grow up and hate us
we should be thinking about what was
done to them and hate that
despise that that it's ugly you see when
people carry out a terrorist attack
they're not considering
the lives of the civilians in these
places so those that perpetrate the 9 11
attacks are not seeing
the thousands of people that they killed
the human beings the Lives Many of whom
are Muslim by the way actually no one of
them was a very active Muslim and
Islamic circle of North America
I mean
they didn't see those stories right
when you drop a bomb
on this many people when you drone
people and you say oops collateral
damage
we were looking for one person killed 40
people and there's no count no names
nothing that can be recalled in the
American memory
that's a problem a fundamental issue
with how we treat the rest of the world
right so
I'm an American I I think that I'm
responsible to the extent that I have to
critique these policies and I have to
try to you know challenge America to
deal with the world differently
and when I go overseas
when I'm around Muslims in the Muslim
world right in the Middle East and in
the Muslim world
you know I have to I'm speaking as a
Palestinian American Muslim who grew up
in south Louisiana I've got a complex
background here right a lot of
experiences here that I'm grateful for
because they all contribute to
uh who I who I am and who what I know
and what I've been I think they're all
enriching I wouldn't relinquish the
Palestinian part I wouldn't relinquish
the American part and I certainly
wouldn't relinquish the Muslim part
but it's helping people consider
what they're not seeing and when you can
dehumanize entire groups of people
to where you can reduce them to chalk
casualty counts and not be able to
recall a single story
then you have to take a step back and
ask yourself what are we becoming
right what are we becoming not a single
victim of Afghanistan or Iraq millions
of people not a single person
can the average American
conjure in their head
if you apply
this to a very difficult topic of Israel
and Palestine
speaking of which right
you have been critical of the policies
of the state of Israel but as we've
mentioned very supportive of Jewish
people you have a lot of friends rabbis
and
Jews in general here in Dallas and
across the world
uh what is the difference to you in that
part of the world between politics and
religion so in this case Zionism and
Judaism uh both terms broadly defined
both terms broadly defined so I say that
because those terms
there's technical definitions and
there's how they're popularly used and
so you have to be kind of sure just like
we said with islamophobia these terms
are they become politicized so just
generally speaking I think Zionism
has to do with the with uh with politics
and Judaism has to do with the religion
it's a great complexity like to a lot of
people like wait a minute right and you
got to take a step back and wonder why
there are so many Zionist anti-semites
in America
and there are so many anti-zionists who
are far from being
anti-semites anti-zionism that are
opposed to the ideology that are opposed
to the implications of it
look uh I think that it's fundamentally
secular
um when you think about it there is an
ethno supremacism there is
I am the child of of Palestinians that
were forcibly displaced from their land
I've never been able to go to where my
parents my grandparents are from
I've never been able to see that land
I've never been able to access that I
have cousins that I'll never be well I
shouldn't say never inshallah God
willing I will need them but that I've
only been able to speak through a phone
face time zoom
um I think that
it's important for us to separate
criticism of Israel's policies
from anti-Semitism in fact it's an
injustice
it cheapens anti-Semitism when you throw
every person who is opposed to Zionism
or opposed to Israel's policies and the
bucket of being anti-semites
it's it's wrong it cheapens it it
doesn't do justice to it
and I think it's important for us to
have a meaningful conversation about
America's support for Israel listen
there are terms
that are important here so I'm gonna
throw out these these big terms right
apartheid
occupation
ethnic cleansing these are terms that
are legal terms
there are objective thresholds here
for apartheid occupation ethnic
cleansing
the threshold of apartheid has been
crossed according to
multiple the most respectable human
rights organizations in the world these
are the organizations that you will
champion and that you will use and every
single other conflict to justify your
own policies
but that threshold of apartheid has been
passed according to Human Rights Watch
according to Amnesty International
according to the Harvard Law review
the threshold of apartheid has been
crossed there's a legal terminology
there two sets of laws for two separate
people you have a displaced people that
are forcibly
being removed that are being treated
differently that are stateless that are
undergoing daily humiliation that live
behind an apartheid wall that live under
a different set of policies that are
routinely bombarded that have lost their
ability to free movements that have lost
their ability to access to basic
necessities of human life there are
legal definitions here I don't see how
any objective human being can read those
reports on apartheid and the threshold
crossed for apartheid and walk away from
that and say that this is just Jews and
Muslims that don't like each other
there's a legal definition here
occupation
when Israel was created in 1948
you will find many Jews who are opposed
to Zionism and I think this is important
you know to talk to Jews who are opposed
to Zionism and they are many
uh that will say that we were told that
it was a land without a people
for a people without a land
the problem with that was there were
people there
our ancestors 750 000 Palestinians
expelled in the nakba and many
Palestinians that have been removed and
harassed and that are treated in
horrific ways and the occupation is
expanding it is in the legal occupation
the settlements are still expanding
and the United States enables that
occupation with its funding with its
unconditional support unwavering support
of Israel
and it does so in a way that completely
undermines any of its claims
to being a beacon of freedom of the in
the world because it is in plain sight
now that the world can see what is
happening in what is happening in
Jerusalem what is happening with these
expanding settlements everything that
flies in the face of any claim to
wanting a peaceful solution the children
in Gaza when I talk about dehumanization
the children that were on the face of
the New York Times which is historically
one of the most anti-palestinian
newspapers in America the faces of the
children of Gaza
America
and many parts of the world are now
seeing it
we have been saying for a very long time
this is apartheid this is an occupation
this is an injustice the world needs to
check it hold it accountable
South Africa which experienced apartheid
Nelson Mandela Desmond Tutu all of those
that fought apartheid in South Africa
said that Palestinians are living under
apartheid and that the same strategies
that check apartheid in South Africa
need to be used to hold Israel
accountable for apartheid with the
Palestinians
it's impossible for us
as Palestinians
to Simply say
that we should give up on this cause
all the odds are stacked against us
but when you have you know videos coming
out of the Israeli armies you know
spewing skunk water
skunk water sewage water on worshipers
leaving in aksa
um
far-right leaders now taking the
government
and the so-called only democracy in the
Middle East prohibiting a Palestinian
flag being raised anywhere around
American reporters Serena
Palestinian American Christian reporter
palestine-american Christian reporter
one of the most prominent journalists in
the Middle East
shot in the face
Plain Sight
and All America could say was all the
American government could say was if it
turns out that it's indeed Israel that
Israel is responsible for the death of
an American journalists then we will
hold them accountable
nothing not a peep
it was a shame
to see that happen and it just
solidified to us that whether it's a
Democratic president or a Republican
president unfortunately the support for
Israel
is enabling it to continue to wipe out
the Palestinian population
from its historic lands and so
we see that happening and I'll say this
as well
people ask me about the Abraham Accords
I say you know you are
talking about faith between are you
talking about peace between communities
of faith and protecting communities of
Faith why are you opposed to the Abraham
Accords I think that the name of Abraham
should not be used and I wrote an
article called why I opposed the Abraham
Accords the name of Abraham should not
be used to justify arms deals that only
further disenfranchise the abused
population of the Palestinians where you
know you have quote unquote Muslim
regimes making peace with Israel and
that's being used against the
Palestinian people who are only further
disenfranchised from having a voice in
their own fate
for the sake of American Arms deals and
security and economic benefits
it's despicable it's repulsive talk to
the people
speak to people on the ground there see
what's happening with your own two eyes
and think about the Injustice where
our tax payer dollars are being used
to suppress the people and what legally
meets the definition by every objective
standard of apartheid of occupation of
ethnic cleansing and it's ongoing and
it's happening in real time and it's
becoming more blatant
with a regime now that's Unapologetic of
even expressing
what the policies have already done
and that is the removal of a people uh
forcible removal of a people because
the government knows that the United
States support is unconditional
gave hope that Jews Muslims and
Christians in this land will
live in peace one day together
have a basic respect for each other's
Humanity
look
this isn't a religious conflict I think
that's fundamentally one of the problems
so even the question is not the correct
question it's not the correct question
this is not a religious conflict yes
religion is invoked yes there there are
religious elements
but
uh there are many Jews
that are opposed to what is happening
right now towards the Palestinians many
and I would I would recommend
you know serious discussion with even
people whose perspectives have grown
Peter bynart being an example
uh Rabbi Simone Zimmerman uh started if
not now
bait to slim an Israeli human rights
organization that also classed it as
apartheid recently there are many Jews
that are opposed to what is happening
right now
Palestinians are also not exclusively a
Muslim population Sharina Morocco was
Christian
there are many Palestinian Christians
that are also being denied entry into
their historic churches and that are
completely bewildered or or uh
absolutely lost in regards to why
American evangelicals have this Ironclad
support for the occupation and have
ignored the plight of Palestinian
Christians
of course I believe Muslims Christians
and Jews can coexist
uh
of course I have hope because I have to
have hope as a person of faith
but as much hope as I have I think
there's a great sense of urgency for
people to open their eyes
learn what's actually happening on the
ground read the reports
stop letting these commentators and
these uh these companies that
are able to generate propaganda own the
narrative there are objective standards
here there are objective measures of
Oppression that need to be considered
here what's happening to Gaza is one of
the greatest atrocities of our time
learn about it right I tell people to
just watch the vice documentaries for
example the mini documentaries I'd sent
them to you as well inside the battle
for Jerusalem I mean think about it a
guy from Long Island New York
can fly to Israel
right
fly into Tel Aviv
and walk into a home that's been
occupied by families for generations and
throw the people out under the full
protection of the military there
and spit on them
historic homes
and when people come up to me and say
we're opposed to islamophobia where
post-islamophobia but they support that
I tell you're not opposed to
islamophobia how can you be opposed to
islamophobia when you
traffic in the same framings and
uh dehumanization
that enables the viciousness towards
Muslims here and Palestinians over there
that they do not deserve to be treated
like equal human beings like full human
beings and that based on historic claims
a guy can fly from New York into a
historic neighborhood in Jerusalem and
kick out generational families with
military guns next to them what does
that sound like how is that how's that
normal right and so I think that if
people take the time to read people take
the time to investigate
then they come to this conclusion
themselves that this is unacceptable
and that you can't put and this is one
of the problems with the framing of
israel-palestine is that you're equating
occupier and occupied you're equating
the two sides of the conflict and it's
not a conflict it's an occupation there
is such a disparity of power here
that you cannot equate the two sides how
you know you can't you know Malcolm X
would say you clip the bird's wing and
then fly and then blame it for not
flying as high as you do you can't you
can't do that to a people and just
equate them with their occupier it's an
atrocity it requires us to challenge it
and I'm hopeful
at the current movement of Muslims
Christians and Jews and people of all
faiths that are saying enough is enough
that thresholds have been crossed here
that this this is an atrocity that
cannot continue you know
this is very personal to me because this
is happening now
what I anticipate and this is what
America did this is what Nelson Mandela
actually predicted with the United
States what I anticipate is that 10
years from now 20 years from now every
American will say how could we have
supported this
and this was terrible and will pay
symbolic you know homage to the
Palestinian cause
but there are people now that are
clinging on for dear life
access to their places of worship access
to their generational homes
right now at this very they're they're
children that are in detention and
there's a Bill in Congress to just stop
I mean
wherever you stand on this issue child
detainment
child detainment child detention
should be a red line right congresswoman
Betty McCullum has put this bill on the
floor of Congress he can't even get that
passed right just to just to at least
censure Child detainment by the IDF
so
people need to look into this deeper
they need to
consider the human element of this
and consider the urgency of it as well
with this new with this new regime it's
only going to unfortunately get get much
worse in the immediate term and so we
have to do something about it
if I may ask you for some advice for a
reason I'll explain maybe in a little
bit uh or maybe I should just explain
now which is I think
because you've talked about islamophobia
because you've been at the center of
so many catastrophic events because you
sort of jump into the fire uh to try to
help people you've been attacked a lot
just in general you've been under stress
it's just you're you're not immune to
stress so
um a part of me wants to ask
foreign
just how psychologically difficult it's
been and where you draw strength and
would you advise if the opportunity is
there
for a person like me for silly kid in a
suit
to go to that part of the world and take
seriously conversations I would divide
it into two categories there's leaders
and there's people
the leaders are sort of these
uh political entities that have their
interests but they also have power
and they want to hold on to power and
then people are just regular people that
have families that just want to
um have basic rights and freedoms and
continue to love their families to
pursue different uh jobs and careers and
lies that they can flourish and so on
those are very kind of different
dynamics of play and if given the
opportunity to speak to leaders for me
would you advise I do it or not and when
I say leaders I mean leaders that
would make the case
the pro Zionist case
and the anti-sinus case and in both
cases I would make it a very challenging
conversations for both of them unlike
today our conversation today you're an
inspiring incredible person I'm a huge
fan of yours you've spread so much love
to the Muslim Community here to the
Jewish Community just everybody loves
you but uh not everybody none yes that's
true not everybody that's true Harry
Potter a lot of people love you yes uh
but this was kind of an inspiring and a
positive conversation it wasn't very
challenging
now although we did tough touch
challenging topics and he did
exceptionally well there but I would do
very challenging conversation with those
leaders in that part of the world is
that a bad idea
all right well let me tell you from now
first and foremost the first part
because I don't want to lose the first
part of your your conversation is it
psychologically stressful very very
um
but when you're
when you're a person of faith and you
believe that
good work will always be rewarded
and that doing the right thing will
always be rewarded eventually
you're able to weather that storm
um
quite a bit
so your wife told you
um
right that's the second thing I was
going to mention is honestly supportive
a supportive family you know my dad's 80
man and he's been through a lot he was
born in 1943 before his five years
before Israel was even created he was
born in Palestine
he suffered displacement he has been
around the world and somehow built
himself up to be a distinguished
professor of chemistry an author an
inventor
um you know grew up uh taking on some of
the most difficult challenges and was
just always a man of principle I always
admired my dad being a man of principle
and like he just tells me man stay the
course stay the course Don't Be Afraid
don't back down I have a supportive
family I have a supportive wife I've got
supportive kids so I have amazing people
around me that keep me grounded for sure
and ultimately obviously faith
and also I'll say this slander doesn't
stand what do you mean by that when
people slander you and it kind of comes
with the territory of a public figure
um it's not going to stand throughout
time because eventually any sincere
person will find the truth
and the only people that will
regurgitate that will continue to do so
so when I get portrayed as
an anti-semite
um
because of my strong takes on Israel and
challenging Israel and then I and I will
continue to do so
it takes just people in gosh like we
know him what are you talking about you
know so slander doesn't stand at least
with the people that are important to
you it might reside on the internet it
might have great rankings and social
media Bots that give attraction but also
psychologically difficulty of course yes
it is difficult it's very difficult and
it's hurtful especially when it comes
from quarters that you would hope that
it doesn't come from
but you know you take a step back you
re-evaluate you lean into your faith and
you lean on the people that are closest
to you and then you keep going
you learned the lessons uh could I be
doing something better could I be doing
something different could I be saying
something better could I be saying
something different are the noble causes
that I want to achieve am I am I doing
Justice by those causes uh how do I grow
out of this right you become wiser
through these things as well
second part of your question though
about what you should do if you're going
to talk to people talk to people
from a place of inquiry I would say talk
to people more so than leaders and
especially some of those who have been
erased from the com from the media
commentary Benjamin Netanyahu gets a lot
of air time
uh you know here in the United States
um he's uh
well spoken you know he speaks perfect
English he's an American as well
um I would challenge him you know on on
some of the things that he has said and
done he has an ongoing corruption case I
I think that
um I think he's a fascist I think that
he's a a person who has done much evil I
think that he has a lot of blood on his
hands and I think that one day he will
be prosecuted for that
uh but I'd say talk to people on the
ground
and people that have been erased talk to
the families that are being displaced I
don't care about the political
leadership I'd much rather you talk to
the people on the ground in East
Jerusalem that have been displaced
um the families talk to Palestinian
Christians talk to the sister of Sharina
Lina Lina abacla who has been who was
extremely disappointed and let down when
Joe Biden went to the region and did not
take her calls did not meet her which
was an absolutely disgraceful move he
should have met with her she's the
sister of an American journalist who was
murdered in Cold Blood talked to Lena
Abu bakla talk to Mitri rahit Mitri uh
interesting person for example he's a
Lutheran he's the head of the Lutheran
Church in Palestine he comes to Dallas
sometimes and talks about the plight of
Palestinian Christians I think if you're
talking to people in leadership you know
obviously there are some that will be
able to represent themselves in English
you know is a very eloquent person for
example
I don't know if you're going to have any
luck getting into Gaza but I'll pray for
you if you do but obviously you know if
you want to talk to everybody you got to
talk to everybody man so well and I also
want to say this very important when you
say whitewashing because I've heard this
a lot so also Ukraine and Russia there's
an interesting line between whitewashing
which is something you definitely should
not do and a deep empathy
for
a large number of human beings it's a
it's a really tricky line to walk and I
also disagree with you about well I
think I don't know if it's a
disagreement but I think I disagree
about leaders I think I agree 100 that
the most important people are the people
on the ground okay but
I think those are extremely important
people to understand not just as Leaders
but as human beings too
and in many cases to have a challenging
conversation but from a place of empathy
from understanding a human being so if
you plan to talk to right wing the
current leadership of Israel
my only request to you
is talk to the victims themselves not
the Palestinian Authority talk to the
victim I know you want to right so I and
I appreciate them yes to the victims
themselves talk to those people that are
being thrown out of their homes and
subjected to the Daily humiliation go to
a checkpoint and walk through the
checkpoint the way that a Palestinian
walks through a checkpoint and tell me
that's not apartheid walk through that
checkpoint crammed in in cages and tell
me it's not apartheid so uh I think
you're a very sincere person uh I think
you're gonna you're gonna do your best
uh I'll be praying for you some of these
such things are harder than others but
yes I feel like we're in the middle of a
negotiation and we've come to a point
where we both agree everyone deserves to
be everyone not everyone deserves to be
but I think there's Great Value and
benefit I let me say I agree with you
and and hearing people even uh tyrants
um hearing them so that you can properly
deconstruct and decipher what you're
hearing but just think of the voices
that don't get hurt third and a lot of
times what's been done to the Muslim
world is and what's being done right now
in the name of the Abraham Accords
what's wrong with the Palestinians the
other Arabs are making peace with them
let me tell you something those regimes
that are signing on to the Abraham
Accords the people are not happy but
they're terrified
of challenging those regimes so if you
go talk to the leaders of some of these
countries that have signed on to the
Abraham Accords
and that are you know in some Twisted
way
making this about religion and peace
you can greatly skew
the narrative
to where Palestinians are just an
inherently disagreeable people that
don't want peace
they just want to live in their homes
they just want to live as full equal
human beings they want the things that
everybody everybody wants
and they're only being further
disenfranchised in the name of peace now
because voices are being Amplified
in the name of peace that are
suffocating voices for justice
laughs
he said hope
as a man of Faith you have hope yes what
gives you hope about
this part of the world and our world in
general when you look across and see so
much conflict so much division happening
what gives you hope
I
I think that if you look through history
we have been through points as a world
where
we almost
we're not going to exist anymore if you
lived in the time
of the Crusades a few lived in some of
these darker moments of history World
War One World War II you probably
thought you weren't going to come out of
this as a world
I have hope in God
and I have hope that godly people people
that are devoted to God and people of
righteousness
can shift things
with his help
um I also believe that younger people I
hope they'll be different
I think younger people
uh
hopefully or using the word hope a lot
you know you might hear inshallah God
willing
um
we'll see the path that we're heading
and
will seek to disrupt
this Bleak trajectory
and bring it back to something else
so here's the thing we live in a time of
hyper exposure that hyper exposure could
paralyze you or it could Empower you it
could
make you completely shut down and say
what's the point of even trying
to help these people out why even talk
about the Palestinians you got these
people here the uyghurs the rohingya you
got what's happening in Honduras
Guatemala El Salvador Brazil South
America Africa Ethiopia
Somalia it's so much and it's it's it
can be overwhelming to a person who
cares
but you ultimately realize
that the difference that you can make
can become a much greater difference
even if it's after your lifetime I'll
tell you actually a story that I
remember the first time went to Syria
Syrian refugee camps
and you deal with people
and this deeply human way uh for me the
most clarifying parts of the world are
the refugee camps
it's where I feel the most Clarity in
life
about what I'm supposed to be doing in
life you go to the refugee camps and
then after you interacting with these
people and you know maybe giving a few
people some trailer homes and some food
and something to sustain themselves some
coats and blankets you drive out of the
refugee camps
back to where you're staying
and the camps get bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and the people get
smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller
but then you realize
that it might be that that small section
that I touched
is going to be the change that affects
all of them
what's going to happen to that
12 year old boy
that has seen
the horrors of this world
and that is absolutely committed
to uplifting his people and bringing
about a change
being responsible for the plight of his
people and so when I look at any
section of Devastation in the world
you never know which part of it that
you're going to touch that's going to
change everything by the grace of God by
the help of God
so you keep trying to do your part you
know the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him said that the most beloved of Deeds
to God are the consistent ones even if
they're small the small Act of Charity
that small smile that small act of
kindness that small prayer might go a
long way if he blesses it so keep
chipping away chipping away chipping
away
do not be paralyzed by the scale of the
division just uh
chip away at it Chip Away small step at
a time that's like I suppose all of us
can do that young people can do that
just one person at a time try to help
yes absolutely absolutely Omar you're an
incredible person you're an inspiration
you know uh I think you mentioned uh you
came to Dallas for a podcast and instead
you got a friend so it's a it's an honor
to be uh your new friend and uh I think
it's time to go pray absolutely yeah I
hope it's okay that I join you and uh at
least in movement in prayer thank you so
much I appreciate you coming down it's
been an absolute pleasure
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Allah
Allah
Allah
all right
so much
I'm sure you don't want to come back go
round two yeah
[Music]
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Omar Suleiman to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
Muhammad Ali
impossible is just a big word thrown
around by small men who find it easier
to live in a world they've been given
and to explore the power they have to
change it impossible is not a fact it's
an opinion impossible is not a
declaration it's a dare
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time